Hey, hey, will Arnett. Good morning. You're jumping out. You keep going, hey, hey, Will Arnett all the time. I know. What's going on with that? I got him doing this new thing, where I tell people his first name and last name. I can't speak without saying the full name.
嘿，嘿，威尔·阿奈特。早上好。你跳出来了。你一直说，嘿，嘿，威尔·阿奈特。我知道。那是怎么回事？我让他做这个新把戏，就是我告诉别人他的名字和姓氏。我不说全名就没法说话。
Like Tommy Lee Jones. You just don't say Tom Jones. You say Tommy Lee Jones. I bet his friends don't say, hey, Tommy Lee Jones. You want a glass of water? I think they probably do. No, they probably say, hey, you want some water. Okay. Hey Will.
就像汤米·李·琼斯。你不能只说汤姆·琼斯。你要说汤米·李·琼斯。我敢打赌他的朋友们不会说，嘿，汤米·李·琼斯。你想喝杯水吗？我想他们可能会。不，他们可能会说，嘿，你想喝点水吗。好吧。嘿，威尔。
See? There we go. Now we're meeting the real Sean. Now we can start an old news marvellous. Smart. Last. Smart. Last. Smart.
看到了吗？这就对了。现在我们见到了真正的肖恩。现在我们可以开始《聪明清单》了。聪明。清单。聪明。清单。聪明。
Last. Smart. Last. So listener, we're trying to figure out, we're trying to figure out why Sean is late this morning. He's never late. So we're actually worried about him.
清单。聪明。清单。那么听众朋友们，我们正在试图弄清楚，我们正在试图弄清楚为什么肖恩今天早上迟到了。他从不迟到。所以我们真的很担心他。
We're starting to think, how would Sean die? We're saying you could choke on egg salad or maybe burn himself beyond recognition on a hot dumpling or something like that from Chin Chin.
我们开始想，肖恩会怎么死？我们说你可能会被蛋沙拉噎住，或者可能被“秦秦”餐厅的热饺子之类的东西烫得面目全非。
Yeah, or just like he sees fries in the fryer and he just goes face first into it. They're like, no, no. But you know what, here's the other possibility is that Sean's sleep, his sleep hygiene is terrible. So he wakes up kind of at like three
是啊，或者就像他看到油炸锅里的薯条，然后脸直接栽进去。他们会说，不，不。但你知道吗，还有另一种可能性，那就是肖恩的睡眠，他的睡眠卫生太糟糕了。所以他大概在三点
or four and he'll stay up and then he'll go back to bed at like eight. And there's a chance, maybe I should ring the house. Should I call the house? Well, but he doesn't, he sleeps with a fan on. And what else? What else did he have
或四点醒来，然后他会熬着，然后在八点左右回去睡觉。很有可能，也许我应该给家里打个电话。我应该打给家里吗？嗯，但他不会，他睡觉时开着风扇。还有什么？还有什么他
to the hotel room on our trip? Like a fan had to be brought in and wasn't like an extra pillow or a knitted blanket or something that was something specific. A weighted blanket, hang on, I'm calling the house phone. Oh my God. I hope he's got a real fun outgoing message. Get that up next
在我们的旅行中带到酒店房间里了？就像必须带一个风扇，还有不是多余的枕头或针织毯子之类的，那是某种特定的东西。加重毯，等等，我正在打家里的电话。天哪。我希望他有一个非常有趣的留言。把它放到
to the mic. Yeah. Just call my landline. Hey, are you going to do the show with us? Or what do you think? It's 10.30. No, it's 10.15. Oh, jeez. I'm coming right now. Okay. Oh, jeez. Surprise guest, please don't respond, but thank you
麦克风旁边。是啊。打我的座机就行。嘿，你要和我们一起做节目吗？还是你怎么想？现在10点半了。不，是10点15分。哦，天哪。我马上就来。好吧。哦，天哪。惊喜嘉宾，请不要回应，但非常感谢
so much for your patience. He's moments away. We appreciate it. Really appreciate it. Surprise guest. What kind of shape is his hair going to be in when he, he has time to grab a hat. Yeah. I don't think he's done one without a hat, has he? I think he sleeps in a hat. I think he showers with showers of the t-shirt on for sure.
你们的耐心。他马上就到。我们很感激。真的很感激。惊喜嘉宾。当他来的时候，他的头发会是什么样子，他有时间抓顶帽子。是啊。我想他没做过不戴帽子的节目，对吧？我想他戴着帽子睡觉。我想他洗澡时肯定也穿着T恤。
Well, you know, like twizzing it before Christmas, like an old time sleeping cap. All right, so Will, so today you're going, you say you're going to play nine holes of golf. You're going to, you've already worked out. Anything else that's going to help the world for you today? I'm adjusting
嗯，你知道，就像圣诞节前那样，像老式的睡帽。好吧，威尔，所以今天你要去打九洞高尔夫球。你要去，你已经锻炼过了。今天还有什么能帮助世界的事情吗？我正在调整
my, my recording. I've got a new mic because I'm taking a mic with me because I have to record smartlist from Singapore. So I'm taking that. The boys sent me a nice Can't wait for the technical difficulties on those records. No. Really? I mean, do I have a lot of
我的录音。我有一个新麦克风，因为我要随身带一个麦克风，因为我必须从新加坡录制《聪明清单》。所以我带着那个。伙计们给我寄了一个，等不及那些录音出现技术故障了。不。真的吗？我是说，我这边有很多
technical difficulties on my end? You've been known to test one too. No, look at the hair. I'm so you guys, I'm so sorry. I hate that feeling of being late. Oh, I thought it was 1030. Yeah. Well, it wasn't look at your calendar.
技术故障吗？你可是出了名的也测试过一个。不，看看这头发。伙计们，我太抱歉了。我讨厌那种迟到的感觉。哦，我以为是10点半。是啊。好吧，并不是，看看你的日历。
Does it say 1015? Let me look. Take a look right now. I'm going to look right now. It says, you know what, guys, it says 1015. Yeah, it does. Well, you just till kind of a little bit on a sugar high from last night from Scottie's big birthday sware. Was it an ice cream party?
上面写着10点15分吗？让我看看。现在就看一眼。我马上看。你知道吗，伙计们，上面写着10点15分。是啊，确实。好吧，你只是因为昨晚斯科蒂盛大的生日派对而有点糖分过高。那是冰淇淋派对吗？
Did you get into a Sunday? No, I often not to I had you know, I made him a cake with some stupid picture of himself on the top of the cake from the $20 cake lady. Yes, she's amazing. And and I had and I said, Scottie
你吃圣代了吗？不，我通常不吃，我你知道，我给他做了一个蛋糕，上面有他自己的一张傻照片，是那个20美元蛋糕女士做的。是的，她太棒了。然后我说，斯科蒂
goes, how much, how big a piece do you want? I go, I'm not even kidding. Cut me half of the cake. Did you eat? Did you eat the full half? Yeah, ate the whole half. How about if you see I'm not even kidding. Cut me the whole half. And he goes, I didn't think you were kidding. I know you. Sean, what would you do if
说，你想要多大一块？我说，我真没开玩笑。给我切半个蛋糕。你吃了吗？你吃了整整一半吗？是啊，吃了整整一半。如果你看到我说我真没开玩笑，给我切整整一半。他说，我没想到你是认真的。我了解你。肖恩，如果你
let's say Steven Spielberg called you today and he said, listen, Sean, I need you for this part. And the guy, the machinist to know, but he's he's a he's a lifeguard at a pool and and there's lots of dialogue that talks
假设史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格今天给你打电话，他说，听着，肖恩，我需要你演这个角色。那个家伙，机械师知道，但他是一个游泳池的救生员，而且有很多对话谈论
about how sculpted his body. How long do you think it would be possible for you at all? This is for Steven Spielberg to what if he then said and you're like, oh, I'll get in shape and go, no, no, no, that's for the other guy. We need somebody to play the flotation device. But do you would you take
他的身材有多健美。你觉得你完全有可能做到吗？这是史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格要求的，如果你当时说，哦，我会去健身，然后他说，不，不，不，那是给另一个人的。我们需要一个人来扮演漂浮装置。但你会接受
on a role where you had to get to sculpted shape and you only had a month to do well. Now that's an interesting question because I always say, like I've lost weight for health reasons or whatever in two weeks or three weeks and knowing that I can do it that fast makes me not do it.
一个需要你练出健美身材的角色，而且你只有一个多月的时间吗？嗯，那是个有趣的问题，因为我总是说，比如我为了健康原因或其他什么在两三周内减掉了体重，知道我能那么快做到，反而让我不去做了。
When did you try that though as we get older gets exponentially harder so much harder now. Trust me. All right. Well, you guys would know. But neither one of you guys are neither one of you guys are out of shape. But I'm just saying you love your treats. You couldn't have any treats.
不过你什么时候尝试过那个，随着我们年龄增长，难度呈指数级增加，现在难多了。相信我。好吧。嗯，你们会知道的。但你们俩都没有身材走样。但我只是说你喜欢你的零食。你不能吃任何零食。
But wait, you'll see the documentary that we filmed because I'm fat as a house. No, you're not. Oh, yeah. You're not here. The other thing, Jay, I will say this. You like your treats too. You just deprive yourself. You live in a state of absolute deprivation because it blows my mind. It's like
但等等，你会看到我们拍摄的纪录片，因为我胖得像头猪。不，你没有。哦，是的。你不在。还有一件事，杰伊，我会说这个。你也喜欢你的零食。你只是克制自己。你生活在一种绝对的匮乏状态中，因为这让我很震惊。就像
the warden has you on a tight on a pretty tight sketch. Oh, she sure does. And she shames you. I've seen her shame you on food, especially on a Saturday night. Remember somebody brought the warden. Remember somebody brought that gooey cake a couple weeks ago on the Saturday night and
狱卒把你管得很严。哦，她确实管得很严。而且她羞辱你。我见过她在食物上羞辱你，尤其是在周六晚上。记得有人带了那个狱卒。记得几周前周六晚上有人带了那个黏糊糊的蛋糕，而且
amongst the treats that was so good. I brought those. No, no, no, no, you didn't bring. No, you didn't. You brought a bag of cookies from the back of your pantry that was shattered. Every single cookie was in just in like, you brought a bag of tates. Yeah, tates that had been dropped off behind
在那些零食中，那太好吃了。我带的那些。不，不，不，不，你没带。不，你没有。你从储藏室后面拿了一袋饼干，都碎了。每一块饼干都像，你带了一袋泰特饼干。是啊，泰特饼干，掉在
your car. You backed up to pick it up accidentally ran it over, then grabbed it, then brought it and dumped it into a bowl as dessert. Kind of true. You're like, hey guys, I brought a really special dessert and he brought it to the tates like, oh cool, we can all go to Safeway, man. We know where to shop.
你的车后面。你倒车时不小心压过了它，然后捡起来，然后带过来，倒进碗里当甜点。有点真实。你就像，嘿伙计们，我带了一个非常特别的甜点，然后他带了泰特饼干，就像，哦酷，我们可以去西夫韦超市，伙计。我们知道去哪买。
Like, what are you doing? Anyway, no, no, listen, this is what, go ahead. Well, I was just saying somebody else's guest and I was like, hey, do we chocolate cake type brownie thing and Jason really liked it and he took a couple of bites and then the warden shot him a look. I looked up and
就像，你在干什么？总之，不，不，听着，这是什么，继续。嗯，我只是说别人的客人，我就像，嘿，我们有巧克力蛋糕之类的布朗尼，杰森真的很喜欢，他吃了两口，然后狱卒瞪了他一眼。我抬头
found the warden's eyes. She was like, she's going to throw him in the hole for 10 days. Listen, this is my life would be a disaster without my better half. Okay. But now look at this. I'm drinking tea and it
看到了狱卒的眼睛。她就像，她要把他关进小黑屋10天。听着，没有我的另一半，我的生活将是一场灾难。好吧。但现在看看这个。我正在喝茶，它
tastes like candy because I put like sugar in it and cream. Because you still didn't have enough sweet in your palette from last night. You know, Sean, can I just say this and I don't want to plug this brand, but they're really good. I use that Trulia now, which is like a natural, like it's a sweetener. Yeah, you mean the ones with carcinogens
尝起来像糖果，因为我往里面加了糖和奶油。因为你昨晚的味蕾还没尝够甜味。你知道，肖恩，我能说这个吗，我不想给这个品牌打广告，但它们真的很好。我现在用那个Trulia，这就像一种天然的，就像一种甜味剂。是啊，你是说那些含有致癌物质的
in them? No, no, no, no, no. It's a plant ding dong. Hey, listen. So, Stevie is the best. Listen, when we're, when we're, when I'm giving, when I'm one of the people giving eulogy saying like, he was really concerned about carcinogens. How do you die diabetes? But man, he was
吗？不，不，不，不，不。那是植物，笨蛋。嘿，听着。所以，史蒂夫是最棒的。听着，当我们，当我们，当我是在做悼词的人之一，说像，他真的很担心致癌物质。你怎么死的？糖尿病？但伙计，他
worried about the carcinogens. It's fucking like, I know, I know. It's so nice try. It's really bad. Well, let me tell you about somebody who just seems incredibly healthy. All right.
担心致癌物质。这他妈的就像，我知道，我知道。太好了，试一试。真的很糟糕。好吧，让我告诉你一个看起来非常健康的人。好吧。
Her whole thing is just a healthy glow. Her talent just radiates health and you're so lazy. You're so lazy. I just try, I was trying to blend.
她的整个状态就是一种健康的红润。她的才华散发着健康，而你太懒了。你太懒了。我只是试着，我试着融入。
Wasn't that a nice transition? Here we go. Guys. Start at the top. Just let her take over because she's the best. I've never seen you phone it. I know I'm not phoning anything in. I'm just pissed off about something this morning and I don't want to drag it into the podcast. Don't.
那不是一个很好的过渡吗？我们开始吧。伙计们。从头开始。就让她接管吧，因为她是最好的。我从来没见过你敷衍了事。我知道我没敷衍任何事。我只是今天早上对某事感到生气，我不想把它带到播客里。别带。
We have one of our best actors going. All right. She's been doing incredible work for about 25 years, yet she's more than 10 years younger than all of us. All right. She's got two Emmys, two Globes, two Sags, two Critics Choice Awards. She's an LA native.
我们有我们最好的演员之一。好吧。她做了大约25年的不可思议的工作，然而她比我们所有人都年轻10岁以上。好吧。她有两座艾美奖，两座金球奖，两座演员工会奖，两座评论家选择奖。她是土生土长的洛杉矶人。
She's got a British dad, a Swedish mom. She's got a Chinese parrot that speaks Dutch. She can explain. This is Elizabeth Moss, everybody. Oh my God. Oh my gosh, I love you. Elizabeth
她有一个英国爸爸，一个瑞典妈妈。她有一只说荷兰语的中国鹦鹉。她可以解释。这就是伊丽莎白·莫斯，各位。天哪。哦，天哪，我爱你。伊丽莎白
Moss. Elizabeth, I'm sorry. I was so fascinated about the Chinese duck or parrot that speaks Dutch. Ducks don't. Wikipedia is always accurate. It's so nice to meet you.
莫斯。伊丽莎白，对不起。我对那只说荷兰语的中国鸭子或鹦鹉太着迷了。鸭子不会。维基百科总是准确的。很高兴见到你。
She's got real fancy lights in her shot guys. She lives in a nice home. They're a little much. I will say Sean, though, I did have a piece of cake last night and I was here on time. Wow. Good for you. It's because you didn't have half a cake. You just had a piece. Good for you.
她的镜头里有很漂亮的灯光，伙计们。她住在一个漂亮的房子里。有点过头了。不过我会说肖恩，我昨晚确实吃了一块蛋糕，而且我准时到了。哇。为你高兴。那是因为你没吃半个蛋糕。你只吃了一块。为你高兴。
I loved that. Elizabeth, the last time I saw you, we kissed. Oh, that's great. Yeah. We should just leave it there. Next question. Anything else? What were you celebrating last night? The memory of that kiss with Will Arnett? What was the cake for? Yes.
我喜欢那个。伊丽莎白，上次见到你时，我们接吻了。哦，那太棒了。是啊。我们应该就此打住。下一个问题。还有别的吗？你昨晚在庆祝什么？对那个和威尔·阿奈特接吻的记忆？蛋糕是为什么吃的？是的。
Absolutely no reason whatsoever except I wanted cake. Really? So I ordered cake. Yeah. Wait, like an Uber Eats order cake? Yeah. Come on. Seamless. Yeah, from Magnolia Bakery. Just ordered cake. Yeah. I was craving cake like that icing that they have. Sure.
绝对没有任何理由，除了我想吃蛋糕。真的吗？所以我订了蛋糕。是啊。等等，像Uber Eats订的蛋糕？是啊。来吧。Seamless。是啊，从木兰烘焙坊。刚订的蛋糕。是啊。我渴望那种蛋糕，那种他们有的糖霜。当然。
And I live in New York and I was like, you know what? I can have that if I want. So I ordered it. Do you take care of yourself like that? Like when you want something and you're like, you know, I'm going to treat myself. I'm just going to go ahead and do it. For the most part. Not so much. When I'm working, I'm a little bit more. I try to be a little bit healthier
我住在纽约，我就想，你知道吗？如果我想吃，我可以吃。所以我订了。你那样照顾自己吗？比如当你想要什么东西时，你会想，你知道，我要犒劳一下自己。我就直接去做了。大部分情况下。没那么多。当我工作时，我稍微多一点。我试着稍微健康一点
and a little bit more conducive to the hours. Other treats even, like just like, you know, like, you know what? I've always liked that car. I'm going to get that car or look at that. Nice blouse. Sean, you know, like, Sean does not walk by a blouse he doesn't love. Neither will not pass it. Never met one.
并且稍微更适应工作时间。其他零食也是，就像，你知道，就像，你知道吗？我一直喜欢那辆车。我要买那辆车，或者看看那件漂亮的衬衫。肖恩，你知道，就像，肖恩不会错过他喜欢的衬衫。也不会错过。从来没见过一个。
I hear you. I hear you. I think everything in moderation is okay. I know, but you know what? What's moderation? Yeah. But isn't it kind of like, isn't it kind of, because my brain goes, well, gosh, I was so deprived as a kid because the way we grew up that now I'm like, I'm an adult
我听到了。我听到了。我认为凡事适度是可以的。我知道，但你知道吗？什么是适度？是啊。但这难道不是有点，难道不是有点，因为我的大脑会想，哎呀，我小时候太匮乏了，因为我们长大的方式，现在我就像，我是个成年人
and I can't stop that thing in my head that says I can have anything I want to eat whenever I want it. Like, I don't need permission. We're lucky. Yep. It's not even about the thing itself. It was just about the fact that I could order it if I wanted to and it would come and then I could eat it. What were you watching
我无法停止脑子里那个说我想吃什么就能随时吃什么的声音。就像，我不需要许可。我们很幸运。是啊。这甚至不是关于东西本身。只是关于如果我想订，我可以订，它会送来，然后我可以吃掉它。你在看什么
on TV when the cake arrived? Real Housewives of New York City. Here we go. I want to know about all the guilty pleasures. So have you done all the regions? Have you done Atlanta? A little bit. I've dabbled in everything, but New York and Jersey, the ones I've really focused on
电视时蛋糕到了？《纽约娇妻》。我们开始吧。我想知道所有的罪恶快感。所以你把所有地区都看完了吗？你看过亚特兰大吗？一点点。我涉猎过所有，但纽约和新泽西，是我真正关注的
in New York is definitely the one I've watched multiple times. Can we just give a lot of color though? Pause for a second. What kind of cake was it? I'm interested. Given that you have every opportunity to order any flavor, which one do you get? Any cake in the world.
在纽约绝对是我看过多次的。我们能多给点色彩吗？暂停一下。是什么样的蛋糕？我很好奇。鉴于你有每一个机会订购任何口味，你选哪一个？世界上任何蛋糕。
It was just the Magnolia Bakery, you know, just the white cake with the buttercream frosting. Wow. It's the classic. Really? There's a cupcake, though, right? Yeah, but they also have slices of cake if you don't want to mess around with a cupcake.
就是木兰烘焙坊的，你知道，就是带奶油糖霜的白蛋糕。哇。这是经典。真的吗？有个纸杯蛋糕，对吧？是啊，但如果你不想折腾纸杯蛋糕，他们也有切片蛋糕。
Same thing, different shape. They usually give you exactly same thing. I love cake as well. It sounds like you love cake and I like that about you. I'm a big cake person and when I hear people saying like they don't like cake, I just think, what is, what? What's wrong with that? Well, I prefer pie. Really?
一样的东西，不同的形状。他们通常给你完全一样的东西。我也喜欢蛋糕。听起来你喜欢蛋糕，我喜欢你这一点。我是个大蛋糕迷，当我听到人们说他们不喜欢蛋糕时，我只是想，什么，什么？那有什么问题？嗯，我更喜欢派。真的吗？
So, yeah, I mean that exactly. That's a great example. What kind of pie? Any kind of pie. Hot fruit. What kind of monster are you? Well, pie. I do like a fruit pie, but I like the crispy hot crust, you know. I like soft fruit.
所以，是啊，我的意思是，那正是。那是一个很好的例子。什么派？任何派。热水果。你是什么怪物？嗯，派。我确实喜欢水果派，但我喜欢酥脆的热外壳，你知道。我喜欢软水果。
Warm fruit is disgusting. Yeah, I don't like that. I like pie. I like pie a lot and I like, like, I love like an apple brown Betty, something like that. Boy, that's good. What about a crumble? Sure. What about a pecan? Yeah. Oh yeah, pecan.
温热的水果很恶心。是啊，我不喜欢那个。我喜欢派。我非常喜欢派，而且我喜欢，就像，我喜欢像苹果布朗贝蒂之类的东西。伙计，那很好吃。那碎屑派呢？当然。那山核桃派呢？是啊。哦，是的，山核桃。
Nothing worse for you than a pecan pie. That's the fattiest dessert you can have. Absolutely. Nothing tastes better. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's so sugary and fatty. Wait, now, Elizabeth, do you know this deal with, now, if you knew this, you might not get a slice next time. You get a real cupcake where you take
没有什么比山核桃派对你更糟糕的了。那是你能吃到的最油腻的甜点。绝对。没有什么比这更好吃了。是啊，是啊，是啊。它太甜太油腻了。等等，现在，伊丽莎白，你知道这个交易吗，现在，如果你知道这个，下次你可能就拿不到一片了。你拿一个真正的纸杯蛋糕，你把
the top of a cupcake, you twist it so that it separates from the bottom, flip it over, make a sandwich out of it, and then you don't get the frosting up the nose. Yeah, that's advanced level. Yeah, I think I got that on Reddit. I'll do it tonight. I've been eating cupcakes wrong for years.
纸杯蛋糕的顶部拿下来，扭一下，让它和底部脱离，翻过来，做成三明治，然后你就不会把糖霜弄到鼻子上。是啊，那是进阶水平。是啊，我想我在Reddit上看到的。我今晚就试试。我吃纸杯蛋糕吃错了好多年了。
So, Elizabeth, where are you? So, people call you Liz, do you hate that? Lizzie. Lizzie's perfect. It's so nice to meet you, Sean. You too. I'm such a big fan. Same. Give it another few minutes. And so, you grew up in L.A., I didn't know that.
所以，伊丽莎白，你在哪？所以，人们叫你莉兹，你讨厌那个吗？莉齐。莉齐很完美。很高兴见到你，肖恩。你也是。我是你的超级粉丝。我也是。再给几分钟。所以，你在洛杉矶长大，我不知道。
I did. I grew up in L.A. until I was about 19 and then I moved to New York, so I've lived in New York for over 20 years now. She went there to study dance, guys. She went to New York to study dance. Ask her about dance. Ask her about ballet. Pursuing a ballet career. And then acting got in the way. Go ahead.
我确实。我在洛杉矶长大，直到我大约19岁，然后我搬到了纽约，所以我已经在纽约住了20多年了。她去那里学舞蹈，伙计们。她去纽约学舞蹈。问她关于舞蹈的事。问她关于芭蕾的事。追求芭蕾舞生涯。然后演戏挡了路。继续。
I know you knew so much about me, Jason. Yeah. Wait, do you still do ballet? Do you still dance? No, I wish. I wish. Really? You can dance if you want to. You can leave your friends behind. Song, song, song. So, you're studying dance and ballet
我知道你对我了解这么多，杰森。是啊。等等，你还跳芭蕾吗？你还跳舞吗？不，我希望。我希望。真的吗？如果你想跳舞，你可以跳。你可以把你的朋友抛在身后。歌，歌，歌。所以，你在学习舞蹈和芭蕾
specifically in New York? Yeah. And then what was the acting pursuit just something like, oh, maybe I can book a few commercials and pay for some rent while I'm studying dance, or how did it come about? It was kind of a 50-50. I loved both of them.
特别是在纽约？是啊。然后演戏的追求只是像，哦，也许我可以预订几个广告，在我学舞蹈时付房租，或者它是怎么来的？这有点五五开。我两者都爱。
And I started acting when I was really young. Acting's easier to kind of keep up than dancing, dancing. You have to go, obviously, every day and it becomes your life. Also, there's a fine night. Exactly. And so, at about 15, I had the choice of whether or not to carry on
我从很小的时候就开始演戏了。演戏比跳舞更容易坚持，跳舞。你显然必须每天去，它就成了你的生活。而且有一个终点。正是。所以，在大约15岁时，我有选择是否继续
and go to a school year round and, you know, look at joining a company and everything. 15, which isn't that crazy? Now, looking back, you're like, Jesus, I was a child. I said this on the podcast before. Then don't say it again. Yeah.
去学校全年学习，你知道，考虑加入一个公司之类的。15岁，那不是很疯狂吗？现在回想起来，你就像，天哪，我还是个孩子。我在播客上说过这个。那就别再说了。是啊。
Why would you repeat yourself? Because Elizabeth hasn't heard it. I can see why Sean didn't want to come. He said, I want to show up. I used to do stand-up in L.A. and one of my first opening jokes was terrible was, you know, they say doing ballet is one of the most difficult things
你为什么要重复自己？因为伊丽莎白没听过。我能看出为什么肖恩不想来。他说，我想出现。我以前在洛杉矶做单口相声，我最早的开场笑话之一很糟糕，是，你知道，他们说跳芭蕾是你能做的最困难的事情之一
you could ever do. So I say, just don't do it. Oh, boy. And then when do you tell the joke after that? When do you tell the joke coming? I like it. I would have laughed. Okay, so wait. So, yeah, when I was 15, I decided
你可能永远做不到。所以我说，就别做。哦，天哪。然后你什么时候讲那个笑话？你什么时候讲那个笑话？我喜欢它。我会笑的。好吧，所以等等。所以，是啊，当我15岁时，我决定
I had some sort of mature thinking and thought, you know, gosh, if I keep doing this, if I'm lucky, if I don't get injured, if I'm successful at all, I'm going to be, I think, by, what, 35? Yeah.
我有某种成熟的想法，想，你知道，天哪，如果我继续这样做，如果我幸运，如果我不受伤，如果我有一点成功，我想，到，什么，35岁？是啊。
And now that I'm 40, I'm so glad that I had that sort of decision and made the right one. And I couldn't leave acting either. It was sort of one of those, I could think about a life without ballet, but I couldn't imagine not acting. Acting felt like who I was.
现在我40岁了，我很高兴我有了那种决定并做出了正确的选择。而且我也离不开演戏。这有点像，我可以想象没有芭蕾的生活，但我无法想象不演戏。演戏感觉就像我是谁。
Ballet felt like something I was doing. Well, what was your first professional acting gig? I think my... I was, like, really little. And then I think my first real professional gig was this lifetime movie called Lucky Chances. Chances? Oh, yeah.
芭蕾感觉就像我正在做的事情。嗯，你的第一份专业演戏工作是什么？我想我的……我当时，就像，真的很小。然后我想我的第一份真正的专业工作是这部叫《幸运机会》的Lifetime电影。机会？哦，是的。
Wonderful. I loved it. Sean's familiar. And it was... I played a girl whose mom died and my mom was one of your former guests, Sandra Bullock. Come on. No way. Yeah, she played my mom and I had to find her dead
精彩。我喜欢它。肖恩很熟悉。而且它是……我扮演一个女孩，她的妈妈死了，我的妈妈是你以前的嘉宾之一，桑德拉·布洛克。来吧。不会吧。是啊，她扮演我的妈妈，我必须发现她死在
face down in the pool. I was six or seven years old and I was like, this is awesome. I love this. Let's keep doing this. So you were six or seven years old. She was dead in a pool. You're 40. She was your mom. She's going to love this story.
游泳池里，脸朝下。我当时六七岁，我就想，这太棒了。我喜欢这个。让我们继续做这个。所以你当时六七岁。她在游泳池里死了。你40岁了。她是你的妈妈。她会喜欢这个故事的。
Yeah, she's going to love it a lot. I've never talked to her about it. She's only 42 or 43. You've never talked to her about it? No, I haven't. And I've met her briefly backstage at, like, a thing. And I'm so intimidated by her because I've never had the balls
是啊，她会非常喜欢它。我从来没跟她谈过这个。她才42或43岁。你从来没跟她谈过这个？不，我没有。我曾在某个活动后台简短地见过她。我被她吓到了，因为我从来没有胆量
to bring it up. We'll be right back. SmartList is supported in part by Delta Airlines. You know, whenever I travel, I come home. I feel like a new person. You know that feeling when you go,
提起它。我们马上回来。《聪明清单》部分由达美航空支持。你知道，每当我旅行，我回家。我觉得自己像个新人。你知道那种感觉，当你去，
when you land back into your hometown and you're driving from the airport back home and then you get into your apartment or your house or whatever and you're just like, oh my God, I'm finally back home. Wherever you travel well, you arrive feeling better than when you left.
当你降落在你的家乡，你从机场开车回家，然后你进入你的公寓或房子或任何地方，你只是想，哦，天哪，我终于回家了。无论你旅行得好，你到达时感觉比离开时更好。
Isn't that how every trip should be with new premium experiences on the ground and in the air Delta Airlines raises the bar sky high because it's not about where you're going. It's about how much you enjoy the journey. Wherever you travel, a better experience awaits with Delta Airlines.
难道那不应该是每次旅行都应该有的吗？通过地面和空中的新高级体验，达美航空将标准提高到了天空，因为这不是关于你要去哪里。这是关于你有多享受旅程。无论你旅行到哪里，达美航空都有更好的体验在等着你。
They've partnered with Peloton to offer a new classes in the clouds collection featuring guided breathing exercises led by Peloton instructors. New plant-based dishes provide more sustainable alternatives for in-flight dining along with organic, gluten-free, nutrient-packed snacks. And select Delta Sky Clubs
他们与Peloton合作，提供云端新课程系列，包括由Peloton教练引导的呼吸练习。新的植物性菜肴为机上餐饮提供了更可持续的替代品，以及有机的、无麸质的、营养丰富的零食。部分达美天空俱乐部
offer locally sourced food and beverages through Delta's Fresh Farm Program. With Delta Airlines, you'll enjoy premium products that are better for people and the planet. Delta One's bedding sets are now made with more than 100 recycled plastic bottles each and stowed away in new reusable
通过达美的“新鲜农场”计划提供当地采购的食物和饮料。有了达美航空，你将享受对人和地球更好的优质产品。达美一等舱的床上用品套装现在由超过100个回收塑料瓶制成，并存放在新的可重复使用的
bedding bags. Wherever life takes you, travel well with Delta Airlines. Visit delta.com slash travel well to learn more. Smart List listeners, this episode is brought to you by Zell. Hey, when anyone sends you money or if you need to get paid back, always ask for Zell.
床上用品袋中。无论生活带你去哪里，与达美航空一起旅行。访问delta.com/travelwell了解更多。《聪明清单》听众，本集由Zell赞助。嘿，当任何人给你汇款或者你需要被还钱时，总是要求用Zell。
With Zell, the money goes straight into your bank account. You don't have to download another app because it's probably already in your banking app. It's in over 1,600 different banking apps and it works even if the sender banks somewhere different than you in the U.S. Jason, Will and I use Zell to pay each other back all the time.
有了Zell，钱直接进入你的银行账户。你不需要下载另一个应用程序，因为它可能已经在你的银行应用程序中了。它在超过1600个不同的银行应用程序中，即使发送者在美国的银行与你不同，它也能工作。杰森、威尔和我一直用Zell互相还钱。
So we have a friend that has been in the hospital recently. He's doing fine. And we all decided to send him meals when he goes home just to make it easy for him so he doesn't have to go out, he doesn't have to cook, whatever. So we're taking turns to send on different nights,
所以我们有一个朋友最近住院了。他很好。我们都决定在他回家时给他送餐，只是为了让他轻松点，这样他就不必出门，不必做饭，等等。所以我们轮流在不同的晚上送
different dinners and stuff that he can keep in the fridge. So I bought all of them like every single night of the week and then Jason and Will used Zell to pay me back. It's that simple. Look for Zell in your banking app today. Hey, smart list listener. We get support from FanDuel.
不同的晚餐和东西，他可以放在冰箱里。所以我买了所有这些，就像一周的每一天，然后杰森和威尔用Zell还我钱。就这么简单。今天在你的银行应用程序中寻找Zell。嘿，《聪明清单》听众。我们得到FanDuel的支持。
Football season is underway big time so now is the perfect time to download FanDuel, America's number one sports book because right now new customers get a no sweat first bet up to $1,000. That's free bets back if your first bet doesn't win.
橄榄球赛季正如火如荼地进行，所以现在是下载FanDuel的最佳时机，这是美国第一体育博彩公司，因为现在新客户可以获得高达1000美元的无压力首注。如果你的第一笔投注没赢，那是免费投注返还。
Just sign up with promo code smart list. I mentioned this before that I'm really, really into football. I know it doesn't seem like it, but I really am. I think it's the most exciting sport to watch. I kind of get really into it when I have to stand up if I get nervous and I walk around and I pace around the living room and I really, really scream too loud
只需用促销代码“smartlist”注册。我之前提到过，我真的，真的很喜欢橄榄球。我知道看起来不像，但我确实喜欢。我认为这是最令人兴奋的运动。我有点真的很投入，如果我紧张，我必须站起来，我在客厅里走来走去，我真的，真的尖叫得太大声
and Scotty gets mad and it's a long story. But FanDuel has all your favorite bets from the money line to point spreads to player props. The app is safe, secure and super easy to use and you get your winnings paid fast. So sign up today with promo code smart list for your no sweat first bet.
斯科蒂很生气，这是一个很长的故事。但FanDuel有你所有喜欢的投注，从胜负盘到让分盘再到球员道具。该应用程序安全、可靠且非常易于使用，而且你的奖金支付很快。所以今天用促销代码“smartlist”注册你的无压力首注。
Make every moment more this season with FanDuel official sports book partner of the NFL. 21 plus exclusions apply. C-show notes for full disclaimer. Back to the show. Now here's what I don't understand is, you know, as you were saying as an actor
让这个赛季的每一刻都更有意义，FanDuel是NFL的官方体育博彩合作伙伴。21岁以上，适用排除条款。查看节目说明以获取完整免责声明。回到节目。现在我不明白的是，你知道，正如你所说的，作为一个演员
you can age into all kinds of roles like you're never too old to be an actor because you just play older parts. Why can't that be the case with dancing? Wouldn't you love to see some sort of dancing company of people north of 50? It'd be comedic, right? How dare you.
你可以随着年龄增长进入各种角色，就像你永远不会因为太老而不能成为演员，因为你只是扮演更老的角色。为什么跳舞不能这样？你不想看到某种50岁以上的人组成的舞蹈团吗？那会很滑稽，对吧？你怎么敢。
Comedic. High jumps and stuff. You're waiting for an injury. More napping. Yeah, it's on ABC. It's called Dancing with the Stars. Nice, Sean. Really good, Sean.
滑稽。高跳之类的。你在等受伤。更多小睡。是啊，它在ABC上。它叫《与星共舞》。不错，肖恩。真的很好，肖恩。
Okay, so thanks guys. Elizabeth, wait, I just had this conversation with a friend of mine the other day about parenting and like, this friend of mine, I see him at the gym. He's got two kids. He's a super nice guy.
好吧，谢谢伙计们。伊丽莎白，等等，我前几天刚和我的一个朋友谈过关于育儿的事，就像，我的这个朋友，我在健身房见到他。他有两个孩子。他是个超级好人。
And he sang a little bit. Oh, that's what you do at the gym. You talk to people. And he sang a little bit. And I go, oh, you have a, you actually can sing like you have a nice voice. He goes, yes, don't tell anybody. I go, what do you mean?
他唱了一点。哦，这就是你在健身房做的事。你和人聊天。他唱了一点。我说，哦，你有一个，你实际上可以唱歌，就像你有一个好嗓子。他说，是的，别告诉任何人。我说，你是什么意思？
He goes, it just makes me shy. Oh, no, you need to sing in front of your kids. You need to like let them know that you can be expressive and extroverted and fearless and all of those things. So did you have, because for kids to dance, I think is very intimidating.
他说，这只是让我害羞。哦，不，你需要当着你孩子的面唱歌。你需要让他们知道你可以表达自己，外向，无畏，以及所有这些事情。所以你有吗，因为对孩子来说，跳舞，我认为是非常令人生畏的。
So did you have parents that kind of express themselves to you to let you know it was safe to do so? Yeah, my parents are both musicians and the whole family is in the music business, but jazz and blues. And so it wasn't so much about expressing yourself.
所以你有那种向你表达自己，让你知道这样做是安全的父母吗？是啊，我的父母都是音乐家，整个家庭都在音乐行业，但是爵士和蓝调。所以这与其说是关于表达自己。
It was just about being an artist was very acceptable. Being anything else would have been weird. Oh, really? Yeah, and practicing and rehearsing and discipline was something that was very much understood in my household.
这只是关于成为一名艺术家是非常可以接受的。成为任何其他东西都会很奇怪。哦，真的吗？是啊，练习和排练以及纪律是我家里非常理解的事情。
So going to class every day was something very normal. That was what you did. You know, you picked a vocation that wasn't really good at it or you didn't do it. Not that that was ever spoken. It's just sort of in retrospect what I can see.
所以每天去上课是一件非常正常的事情。那就是你做的事。你知道，你选择了一个职业，不是真的擅长它，或者你没做。不是说那是被说出来的。这只是回顾过去我能看到的。
But there were, I mean, everyone was always playing an instrument. You know, we were always going to shows. My first memories were, you know, going to the Greek theater, the beacon or Blue Note New York. Like that was, it was just what I thought life was.
但有，我的意思是，每个人总是在演奏乐器。你知道，我们总是去看演出。我最早的记忆是，你知道，去希腊剧院，灯塔或纽约蓝调之音。就像那是，那只是我认为生活是什么。
Everyone was a musician. My oldest brother, Dennis, he allowed his kids to write on the walls anywhere in the house with crayons any time they wanted. And it was, you know, it was him and his wife.
每个人都是音乐家。我最大的哥哥，丹尼斯，他允许他的孩子随时随地在房子里的墙上用蜡笔写字。而且是，你知道，是他和他的妻子。
It was like, she's like, what are you doing? He's like, you can just paint over it. Let them just draw on the walls. That's really sweet. They were divorced shortly after that, I think, right? Isn't that kind of interesting? You can draw in jail.
就像，她说，你在干什么？他说，你可以把它涂掉。让他们在墙上画画。那真的很甜。他们在那之后不久就离婚了，我想，对吧？那难道不有趣吗？你可以在监狱里画画。
Oh, you're sweet. But Lizzie, did you, are your parents still with us? Yes. Are they still performing as musicians? Are they still doing, still active in their music? Here and there, here and there. My mom is, it's pretty cool, actually.
哦，你真甜。但莉齐，你，你的父母还在吗？是的。他们还在作为音乐家表演吗？他们还在做，还在活跃在他们的音乐中吗？这里那里，这里那里。我妈妈是，其实很酷。
My mom is a blues harmonica player. And to be a female blues harmonica player is actually really rare. And she's really, really good. She doesn't gig as much anymore, but she still plays and she's really good. That's pretty awesome. And your dad, what does your dad play?
我妈妈是蓝调口琴演奏家。作为一个女性蓝调口琴演奏家其实真的很罕见。而且她真的，真的很好。她不再经常演出，但她仍然演奏，而且她真的很好。那太棒了。还有你爸爸，你爸爸演奏什么？
Trombone. No way. Yeah. That's so cool. Do they have a two-man show? No. I would like to see that. That's pretty cool.
长号。不会吧。是啊。那太酷了。他们有双人秀吗？不。我想看那个。那太酷了。
Jason used to have a real rusty trombone used to play, right? Hey, but let me ask you this, Lizzie, the other question is, did they, did they, so they, so, but they performed jazz. Yep. Yeah. And do you, how do you feel about, are you a fan of, everybody,
杰森以前有一个真正生锈的长号，他以前演奏，对吧？嘿，但我问你这个，莉齐，另一个问题是，他们，他们，所以他们，所以，但他们表演爵士乐。是啊。是啊。你觉得怎么样，你是粉丝吗，大家，
are you guys all fans of jazz music? I don't, I don't love it. You don't open it up to the room? Well, yeah. I am. I'm not a jazz fan, but I feel like I'm just one documentary away from being a big fan. Yeah.
你们都是爵士乐的粉丝吗？我不，我不喜欢它。你不向房间开放吗？嗯，是啊。我是。我不是爵士乐迷，但我觉得我离成为大粉丝只差一部纪录片了。是啊。
I appreciate the talent, but I like something to sing back. And a lot of times when they're riffing for two hours, I can't find a melody. Yeah, Sean and I both love classical music. I haven't decided, I can't figure out where I should land on it. I can't figure out if it's cool or not cool to like jazz.
我欣赏这种才华，但我喜欢可以跟着唱的东西。很多时候当他们即兴演奏两个小时时，我找不到旋律。是啊，肖恩和我都很喜欢古典音乐。我还没决定，我弄不清楚我应该在它上面落脚在哪里。我弄不清楚喜欢爵士乐是酷还是不酷。
So I'm still trying to decide and I'm waiting. I'm just sort of trying to garner a consensus whether I should be like... We need to watch Ken Burns documentary. I mean, the Ken Burns, I was going to say, the Ken Burns documentary. Yeah, but that's not going to decide it for me. I need people like, I need like,
所以我还在决定，我在等。我只是在试图收集共识，我是否应该像……我们需要看肯·伯恩斯的纪录片。我的意思是，肯·伯恩斯，我本来想说，肯·伯恩斯的纪录片。是啊，但这不会为我决定。我需要人们像，我需要像，
I need like Steve Malekness to say if it's cool or not from pavement. And then I'll be like, yeah, I like it. Jazz is cool, for sure. Yeah. Yeah, for sure. It's cool. But it's an acquired...
我需要像史蒂夫·马莱克内斯说它是否酷，来自Pavement。然后我会说，是啊，我喜欢它。爵士乐很酷，肯定的。是啊。是啊，肯定的。它很酷。但它是一种习得的……
You're cool, so I believe you. Thank you. It's an, a lot of it's an acquired taste when you get into like the real deep jazz, the real stuff and the improv and everything. It's, it's not for everybody. It's, but I grew up on it. So from, I, I understand it and love it.
你很酷，所以我相信你。谢谢。它是一种，很多是习得的品味，当你进入像真正深度的爵士乐，真正的东西和即兴演奏以及所有一切时。它，它不适合每个人。它，但我是在它上面长大的。所以从，我，我理解它并喜欢它。
And to me, it's, it's very normal sounding. When I was little, I was the one listening to Ella Fitzgerald. And I mean, I was very into... Well, I love that. Yes, exactly. I love that because there's singers. Yes, exactly.
对我来说，它，它听起来很正常。当我小的时候，我是那个听艾拉·费兹杰拉的人。而且我的意思是，我非常投入……嗯，我喜欢那个。是的，正是。我喜欢那个，因为有歌手。是的，正是。
Like that was where I really landed was with, with the crooners and with Gershwin and all of that. For sure. I could, I could like, I memorized all the Gershwin songs when I was like, you know, five years old. You know, so I had no idea when I was a teenager, like who Nirvana was,
就像那是，我真正落脚的地方是与，与歌手和格什温以及所有这一切。肯定的。我可以，我可以喜欢，我背下了所有的格什温歌曲，当我像，你知道，五岁时。你知道，所以我十几岁时根本不知道，像谁是涅槃乐队，
but I could absolutely sing, you know, any Gershwin tune. So that was where I landed. Did you ever go to jazz fest down in New Orleans? No, I never been. I've been to New Orleans a lot, but I haven't been to jazz fest. It's supposed to be great. Do you play?
但我绝对可以唱，你知道，任何格什温曲调。所以那是我的落脚点。你有没有去过新奥尔良的爵士音乐节？不，我从来没去过。我去过新奥尔良很多次，但我没去过爵士音乐节。它应该很棒。你会演奏吗？
I missed it. Do you play something? No, I don't. I kind of learned the piano for a role later. I learned piano and guitar, but just for that movie. But no, I never really learned anything. Because in my family,
我错过了。你会演奏什么吗？不，我不会。我后来为了一个角色学了钢琴。我学了钢琴和吉他，但只是为了那部电影。但没有，我从来没真正学过什么。因为在我家里，
you, you, you got really good at something. So if you didn't have time to practice every day, you know, you might as well just forget about it. Sean, do you wish, do you wish in your family people had gotten good at stuff? Or at least decent. Or just showed up. So, so, so, so we're in New York
你，你，你变得非常擅长某件事。所以如果你没有时间每天练习，你知道，你还不如干脆放弃算了。肖恩，你希望，你希望你的家人能擅长某些事情吗？或者至少像样一点。或者只是露个面。所以，所以，所以，所以我们在纽约
and we're, we're getting some traction in acting. When, when, when did you feel the first real shift and like, oh, here comes possibly a career in, in acting? Was it, was it West Wing? I guess it was kind of West Wing. Or Girl Interrupted, this film I did when I was, I think I was like 15 or 16. Yeah, because there were all these great women in that.
我们，我们正在演艺事业上取得一些进展。当，当，当你在什么时候感觉到第一次真正的转变，觉得，哦，这可能是一份演艺事业？是，是《白宫风云》吗？我想大概是《白宫风云》。或者是《移魂女郎》，那是我大概15或16岁时拍的电影。是的，因为里面有很多很棒的女性。
And, you know, when I'm a writer, Angelina Jolie, Brittany Murphy, Clea Duvall, who I got to work with again later. And so that was kind of the one where I was like, ah, it would be Goldberg, isn't it? Where I was like, oh, this is something I think I'm, I'm good at and really fit well in. And then yeah, the West Wing was like my first like regular job
而且，你知道，当我还是个写作者时，安吉丽娜·朱莉、布兰妮·墨菲、克丽·杜瓦尔，我后来还有机会和她再次合作。所以那部戏让我觉得，啊，应该是戈德堡，对吧？当时我就想，哦，这是我擅长并且非常适合的事情。然后，是的，《白宫风云》是我第一份像样的固定工作
where I felt I had, you know, a place and kind of started to have a community and a group and with all those guys, even though I was just reoccurring, you know, and I was quite young, I was 17 when I started on that job. It was my profile. I bet you started to get stopped on the street and stuff like that. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, I did, I did.
在那里我感到，你知道，有了一席之地，开始有了一个社区和一个团队，和那些家伙在一起，尽管我只是常驻角色，你知道，而且我当时很年轻，我开始那份工作时才17岁。那是我的个人简介。我敢打赌你开始在街上被人拦住之类的。是的，没错。是的，我确实，我确实被拦住过。
How did you adapt to that? Was that odd? It was, it was only odd because I, I was in the first two seasons a lot. The first four, the Aaron Sorkin seasons, I was in more. And the, the, I would get stopped and asked questions about things I didn't know the answers to and, you know, because I wasn't on the show.
你是怎么适应的？那很奇怪吗？它，它之所以奇怪只是因为我，我在前两季里戏份很多。前四季，也就是艾伦·索金执笔的那些季，我出现的更多。而且，我会被拦住问一些我不知道答案的问题，你知道，因为我并没有参与那场戏。
So much mushrooms to Aaron Sorkin do. And you're like, I don't know. God. Ask TSA. They're the ones that went through a bag. Luckily they were not asking. I had him booked for next week. Never mind.
艾伦·索金做了那么多蘑菇。然后你会说，我不知道。天哪。去问TSA（美国运输安全管理局）吧。是他们翻了包。幸好他们没问。我本来下周还要采访他。算了。
They're not asking my 18 year old self that. It's okay. He's never hired me anyway. I don't, he doesn't give a shit what I say. Same. But then you do, but then Mad Men and Lizzie, can I just say, I, I, I watched and, you know, that we're friends with John too and all that.
他们没问我18岁时的那个自己。没关系。反正他从来没雇过我。我不，他根本不在乎我说什么。我也是。但后来你做了，但后来《广告狂人》和莉齐，我能说吗，我，我，我看了，而且，你知道，我们和乔恩也是朋友之类的。
I watched Mad Men. I kind of let it build up for a couple of seasons before I got into it and I watched it all the way through. And you are simply unbelievably fantastic in that. Incredible. You are Lizzie. I, and I've known you a couple of years or what. And I don't know if I've ever actually said that to you,
我看了《广告狂人》。我在开始看之前让它积攒了几季，然后我一口气看完了。你在里面的表现简直好得令人难以置信。太不可思议了。你就是莉齐。我，而且我认识你几年了还是怎么的。我不知道我是否真的对你说过，
but I, I can't believe when, even when I think about what you did and some of the moves that you have and what you do in that show, I honestly, I found it mesmerizing. I find it really, really truly. She knows what she's doing. That's so nice. Thank you.
但我，我简直不敢相信，即使当我想到你所做的一切，以及你在那部剧中展现的一些动作和表现，我老实说，我觉得那太迷人了。我真的，真的觉得。她知道自己在做什么。太好了。谢谢。
Yeah. Wow. I really appreciate that. And no, you have never said that to us. I know, I know. Cause I was embarrassed. And then click and you just slam your laptop down. Like I got what I came for.
是的。哇。我真的很感激。而且不，你从来没对我们说过。我知道，我知道。因为我当时很尴尬。然后点击一下，你就把笔记本电脑合上了。就像说我得到了我想要的。
Wait, she's leaving. Now top of the lake, which is one of my favorites was, was right after that. It was in the middle. Middle of that. Yeah. I think it was like season four or five of Mad Men that I went to go to that in between.
等等，她要走了。现在，《顶湖》是我最喜欢的作品之一，就在那之后。是在中间。在那中间。是的。我想大概是《广告狂人》第四或第五季的时候，我中间去拍了那个。
I also love that. That was really good. And you go down to New Zealand to do that, right? Yeah. That was crazy because I, it was, you know, I'd gotten kind of more famous for, for Peggy and people really liked her. And then that was the first, that was the time actually
我也很喜欢那个。那是真的很棒。然后你去了新西兰拍那个，对吧？是的。那太疯狂了，因为我，你知道，我因为佩吉这个角色变得更出名了，人们真的很喜欢她。然后那实际上是第一次
that I discovered that I could sort of do another character. I was, didn't know really whether or not I was just really good at Peggy. And that was my thing. And wow, how amazing just to be on that one good show. Like that's more than so many people ever get. So this was like a kind of a test for myself as well of could I go and do something else that was completely different
我发现我还能演另一个角色。我当时不知道自己是否真的只是擅长演佩吉。那是我的拿手戏。哇，能出演那一部好剧真是太棒了。这比很多人一辈子能得到的都要多。所以这对我自己来说也是一种测试，看看我是否能去演一些完全不同的东西
with the accent? It was a completely different tone. The character was completely different. And it was hard. It was a very challenging role too. So that was kind of a, for me, the step in my career that was like, Oh, okay. I think I can do this and then I could go do that.
带着口音？那是完全不同的基调。角色也完全不同。而且很难。那也是一个非常有挑战性的角色。所以那对我来说，是我职业生涯中迈出的一步，就像是，哦，好吧。我想我可以做到这一点，然后我就可以去演那个。
And I could make a real meal out of this. Top of the Lake was like my North Star for Ozark because I was trying to build a look and a feel for the show. And I also fell in love with Peter Mullen. And he was, he was my second call right after Laura Linney. How about that? To get, to get the show. I mean, really?
我可以把这个角色演得淋漓尽致。《顶湖》就像是我《黑钱胜地》的北极星，因为我当时正试图为这部剧建立一种视觉和感觉。而且我也爱上了彼得·穆兰。他，他是我继劳拉·琳妮之后的第二个通话对象。怎么样？为了得到这部剧。我是说，真的吗？
I never knew that. And that makes total sense. Yeah, it does make sense. That's really cool. Even your, your title card, which is just five seconds long. You know, like there's no opening credits. It's just that five second thing. And so that's, that's why it's a huge inspiration for me.
我从来不知道。这完全说得通。是的，确实说得通。那真的很酷。甚至你的片头字幕，只有五秒钟长。你知道，没有开场演职员表。只有那五秒钟的东西。所以这就是为什么它对我来说是一个巨大的灵感来源。
Everybody watched that. Well, you say inspirations. They say lawsuit cause, you know, judging by, Jane Campion is real litigious. Deadline is saying right now already. He loves a lawsuit. But then you go, so, so, but then you go, you do, you do Top of the Lake, which I also thought was incredible.
每个人都看了那个。好吧，你说灵感。他们说诉讼，因为，你知道，从简·坎皮恩来看，她真的很爱打官司。《Deadline》现在已经在说了。他喜欢诉讼。但后来你去，所以，所以，但后来你去，你拍了，你拍了《顶湖》，我也觉得那部剧不可思议。
And for me, what it made me do was like Google, I guess it was like, what part of New Zealand was that? It was in, Oh, New Zealand. Queen's Town. Queen's Town. God. And I was like, wow, look at this place.
对我来说，它让我做的事情就是去谷歌搜索，我想那是新西兰的哪个地方？是在，哦，新西兰。皇后镇。皇后镇。天哪。我就想，哇，看看这个地方。
It looks incredible. And then, Oh God, it's so beautiful. Then you go and do Handmaid's Tale. Yeah. And as a Canadian, I feel a sort of sense of ownership on that book because, you know, Margaret Atwood is a great Canadian author.
看起来太不可思议了。然后，哦天哪，太美了。然后你去拍了《使女的故事》。是的。作为加拿大人，我对那本书有一种归属感，因为，你知道，玛格丽特·阿特伍德是一位伟大的加拿大作家。
And we all read it in school. So quite familiar with it. I, again, I was like, this Lizzie Moss, I mean, there ain't nothing she can't do, but we're going to find it. We're going to find the thing she can't do before it's all over. Why would you want to do that? That's not destructive.
我们都在学校读过它。所以相当熟悉。我，再次，我想，这个莉齐·莫斯，我是说，没有什么是她做不到的，但我们会找到的。我们会在一切结束之前找到她做不到的事情。你为什么要那样做？那不是破坏性的吗。
Now, did you, did you read the book on that and pursue it? Or what, or did the script come to you as an offer? Or did you audition? Like, how'd that come about? So I was doing the second season of Top of the Lake in Sydney. And it came my way as a script. And I had read the book years ago, but sort of didn't, you know, really remember it that well.
那么，你，你读过那本书并追求这个角色吗？还是说，剧本是作为邀约给你的？还是你去试镜了？那是怎么发生的？当时我正在悉尼拍摄《顶湖》第二季。剧本就这样传到了我手里。我几年前读过那本书，但，你知道，记得不太清楚了。
So I read the script with sort of fresh eyes, which was great. And I had, Mad Men had only finished like a year before or something. So I really didn't intend to get into another series. You know, I was sort of doing the thing of, okay, I'm now going to go and have all of this time. But then I read this script and it was so good. And then I read, I said, can I see the second one? And I read the second one and I was like, fuck, it's even better.
所以我用一种新鲜的眼光读了剧本，这很棒。《广告狂人》才刚结束一年左右。所以我真的没打算再接一部剧。你知道，我当时正打算，好吧，我现在要给自己留出所有这些时间。但后来我读了这个剧本，它太好了。然后我读了，我说，我能看第二集吗？我读了第二集，我就想，该死，它甚至更好。
So I got on the phone with Hulu and with Bruce and then I said, you know, I want sort of a Warren Littlefield type to come and do this. And because I was obsessed with Fargo and they said, well, what if we brought you Warren Littlefield and then Warren and I got on the phone and he was sort of like, I'll do it if you do it kind of thing. Yeah. And since then he's been sort of my producing mentor.
所以我给Hulu和布鲁斯打了电话，然后我说，你知道，我想要一个沃伦·利特菲尔德那样的人来做这个。因为我沉迷于《冰血暴》，他们说，好吧，如果我们把你沃伦·利特菲尔德找来怎么样，然后沃伦和我通了电话，他就像是，如果你做，我就做那种感觉。是的。从那以后，他就像是我的制片导师。
I love him so much. He's the reason, he's the reason Will and Grace happened. Yeah. Warren was like a big dad figure to Sean and I in our NBC years. Of course. He was big cheese. But also you go to do a show for a streamer that, and you don't know if they're going to do, I mean, like at that point,
我非常爱他。他是，他是《威尔和格蕾丝》得以实现的原因。是的。沃伦在我们NBC的那些年里就像肖恩和我的一位大父亲形象。当然。他是大人物。但你也要为一个流媒体平台拍一部剧，而且你不知道他们是否会做，我是说，就像在那个时候，
but you, and it worked out in like Hulu, you know, it worked out. Wait, did you Sean, did you hear? And my ballet joke was bad. Hulu, listen, he loves Hulu. Sushimi, you know? Sushimi. But the thing was is I hadn't, I wasn't scared of that because of Mad Men. First of all, West Wing NBC wasn't doing a show like that.
但你，它成功了，就像Hulu，你知道，它成功了。等等，肖恩，你听到了吗？我的芭蕾笑话很烂。Hulu，听着，他喜欢Hulu。生鱼片，你知道？生鱼片。但问题是，因为《广告狂人》，我并不害怕那个。首先，NBC的《白宫风云》并没有做过那样的剧。
And then that did well. And then Mad Men was on AMC, which nobody knew what that was. And everybody thought we were on A&E. Yeah, it takes one shot. And then Top of the Lake was on Sundance, which nobody knew what that was. And so I wasn't scared of the new place. I actually really like new places because I feel like you have the space to prove yourself as opposed to chasing a high that they've experienced.
然后那部剧表现不错。然后《广告狂人》是在AMC播出的，没人知道那是什么。每个人都以为我们在A&E频道。是的，只需要一次机会。然后《顶湖》是在圣丹斯频道播出的，没人知道那是什么。所以我并不害怕新地方。我其实真的很喜欢新地方，因为我觉得你有空间去证明自己，而不是去追逐他们已经经历过的高峰。
You kind of, you get to be the one that goes in. They don't really know what they're doing yet or who they are. So they're kind of willing to take more risks. I like that. Do you, I just said to somebody the other day, Don at me, I'm 52 and, you know. What? Withhold, yeah, okay. Wow.
你，你成为了那个进入的人。他们还不知道自己在做什么，或者他们是谁。所以他们更愿意承担风险。我喜欢那样。你，我前几天刚对某人说，Don at me，我52岁了，你知道。什么？保留，是的，好吧。哇。
All the, wow, I can't believe it. But let me just, I realized the other day, I thought, I actually, people go like, I hate change. I'm nervous to change. I'm not nervous of change or risk. I'm not risk averse at all. I love change. I'm, are you scared of change?
所有的，哇，我简直不敢相信。但让我说，我前几天意识到，我想，实际上，人们会说，我讨厌改变。我害怕改变。我不害怕改变或风险。我一点也不厌恶风险。我喜欢改变。你，你害怕改变吗？
No, not at all. I mean, doesn't it, I don't know how you guys feel, but it doesn't kind of come with this lifestyle career in the sense of. There's nothing consistent about it. There's nothing consistent about it. There's no regular job. And of course, you know, you get to a place where you feel more secure, hopefully, but you know, there's no consistency.
不，一点也不。我是说，难道它，我不知道你们感觉如何，但这难道不是伴随着这种生活方式和职业吗？它没有任何一致性。它没有任何一致性。没有固定的工作。当然，你知道，你到了一个你觉得更安全的地方，希望如此，但你知道，没有一致性。
And, and, you know, you, so we're all used to kind of circus people. We're used to moving somewhere for six months and developing a life there and then leaving and never seeing those people again. And, you know, it's, so I think we're all kind of, yeah, embrace change. Did some of that sort of knowledge of how sort of fickle this businesses lead to your, your, your incredible diversification of your, of your capital, your, your, your access in this business with all the producing and the directing that you're doing as you, or is that,
而且，而且，你知道，你，所以我们都习惯了马戏团式的生活。我们习惯了搬到某个地方住六个月，在那里发展生活，然后离开，再也见不到那些人。而且，你知道，所以我想我们都，是的，拥抱改变。那种对这个行业如何反复无常的了解，是否导致了你，你，你对你的资本，你的，你的，你在这一行中的门路进行了令人难以置信的多元化，包括你正在做的所有制片和导演工作，或者那是，
or those pure pursuits, you really love directing, love producing, or, or is it a combo of all that stuff? It's probably more of the latter. It's a bit of a combo, but more of the latter. I kind of fell into it. Not by chance. It was by choice, but on hand maids, they asked me to be a producer. And I said, okay, but I, I don't want it if it's just a title and you're
或者那些是纯粹的追求，你真的热爱导演，热爱制片，或者，或者那是所有这些东西的结合？这可能更多是后者。这有点结合，但更多是后者。我算是误打误撞进入的。不是偶然。是出于选择，但在《使女的故事》上，他们让我担任制片人。我说，好吧，但我，如果这只是一个头衔，而你
just going to put the thing up there and I don't really get to do anything and say anything. I said, so I'd like to really, I remember talking to Warren about it. I said, I'd like to really learn how to do this. I'd like to learn from you. I'd like to like learn from the people who are better at this. And then I started to learn and I started to really love it. And I loved the involvement.
只是要把东西挂在那里，而我并没有真正去做什么或说什么，那我就不要。我说，所以我希望能真正学习如何做这件事。我想向你学习。我想向那些比我更擅长此道的人学习。然后我开始学习，我开始真正爱上它。我爱上了这种参与感。
It gave me on a creative level, not on a control level. I loved how I got to learn so much about after 30 years doing this. I was learning parts of the job that I had no idea about. And then same thing with directing. I loved the show so much. Love the show so much. It's my baby. And after three years of making it, I just wanted to, to tell the story myself.
它在创意层面上给了我参与感，而不是在控制层面上。我喜欢在做了30年之后，我能学到这么多。我正在学习我以前根本不知道的工作部分。然后导演也是一样。我太爱这部剧了。太爱这部剧了。它是我的宝贝。在制作了三年之后，我只是想，自己来讲述这个故事。
I wanted to embrace another part of telling the story. I had no designs on becoming a director. It wasn't something that I thought, oh, this is my, this is the end game. This is what, this is what I can do to keep my career going. But it's something you're really loving and doing more of. Yeah. I really love it. Yeah.
我想拥抱讲述故事的另一个部分。我没想过要成为一名导演。这不是我曾经想过，哦，这是我的，这是终局。这是我，这是我能做的事情来维持我的职业生涯。但这是你真正热爱并做得更多的事情。是的。我真的很喜欢它。是的。
That's so great. I really do. It's so great. Who's your go-to lieutenant in your, in your team, your immediate team there? Your first AD, your DP, your camera operator, like, or your, or your cast? Like, where do you find yourself gravitating with, with directing? That's such a good question. That's such a good question.
那太棒了。我真的喜欢。在你的团队中，你的核心团队里，谁是你的得力助手？你的第一副导演，你的摄影指导，你的摄像师，比如，或者你的，或者你的演员？比如，在导演时，你发现自己倾向于和谁在一起？这是一个很好的问题。这是一个很好的问题。
The DP, I think for me, just because that's the person, I'm obviously, I really love the visual aspect of it. And we're a very visual show. Yeah. It's dramatic. It's beautiful. Yeah. Well, thank you.
摄影指导，我想对我来说，只是因为那个人，我显然，我真的很喜欢它的视觉方面。而且我们是一部视觉感很强的剧。是的。它很有戏剧性。它很美。是的。好吧，谢谢。
So that was actually how I kind of got into the idea of directing was shadowing directors and, and dealing with them so much as they were prepping episodes. And I would always be there and we'd have meetings at my house or their house. And I was very involved and I was learning without realizing I was learning. And we always included the DP because we believe that it's very important that the DP knows what the scene is about and what you're trying to accomplish. And so through that, I got more and more and more into the visual side of it. So yeah, I would say the DP, especially on our show, which is so, and also the locations
所以这实际上是我如何开始接触导演想法的方式，就是跟随导演，在他们准备剧集时与他们打交道。我总是会在那里，我们会在我家或他们家开会。我参与度很高，我在不知不觉中学习。我们总是包括摄影指导，因为我们认为摄影指导知道场景是关于什么的以及你试图完成什么非常重要。通过这种方式，我越来越多地进入了视觉层面。所以是的，我会说是摄影指导，特别是在我们的剧里，这太，还有外景
department, our, our, our locations department is absolutely incredible. And we're very Toronto. Yeah. Oh yeah. You can go over there. If you guys want to shoot, we found a nice parking lot over here. Yeah. She looks pretty good.
部门，我们的，我们的，我们的外景部门绝对令人难以置信。而且我们非常多伦多。是的。哦，是的。你们可以去那边。如果你们想拍摄，我们在这边找到了一个不错的停车场。是的。她看起来相当不错。
Fuck. We'll just, we'll shovel that snow out quick and you can get the trucks in there. No problem. Shut up. Basically. Well, lastly on directing. Jason, I was going to say to you, cause that is a good question. I've never, that's interesting.
该死。我们只要快速把雪铲掉，你们就可以把卡车开进去了。没问题。闭嘴。基本上。好吧，最后关于导演。杰森，我正想对你说，因为那确实是个好问题。我从来没，这很有趣。
Cause I know Sean and I talked about it and he said, he directed that one thing and he said that he really leaned hard on catering. So, but for you, You gotta keep the crew happy. Yeah. That was the most important thing. He'd call him every shot. He'd be like, where are you setting up catering?
因为我知道肖恩和我谈过这件事，他说，他导演了那一件事情，他说他真的很依赖餐饮服务。所以，但对你来说，你得让剧组开心。是的。那是最重要的事。他每次拍摄都会叫他们。他会说，你们把餐饮设在哪里？
They're like, Sean, it's in the shot. He's like, it's okay. We'll paint it out. We'll paint it out. I'm not walking more than 10 steps. But Jay, Jay, who do you lean on Jay? I'm actually curious. I, um, I don't know.
他们说，肖恩，它在镜头里。他说，没关系。我们会把它涂掉。我们会把它涂掉。我不会走超过10步。但杰伊，杰伊，你依赖谁，杰伊？我其实很好奇。我，嗯，我不知道。
Pete Thorell is the first AD that I've worked with a ton and I just think that he's just incredible. What he does, he does so many things he's not even paid to do with every department and he's just sort of like the secret weapon. But is that because it's him or is that, is that your go-to? AD is assistant director. I do think the first AD is, I mean, the first AD is, in my opinion, the most important person on the set.
皮特·索雷尔是我合作过很多次的第一副导演，我只是觉得他简直不可思议。他所做的事情，他做了很多他甚至没有报酬去做的事情，涉及每个部门，他就像是秘密武器。但那是因为他本人，还是那是，那是你的首选？AD是助理导演。我确实认为第一副导演是，我是说，第一副导演，在我看来，是片场最重要的人。
They're, they're running everything. And if they're not, if they're not into it, if they don't create a good harmonious It's so true. It's just. Sean, Sean, you started, you started to say for Tracy. So, so for Tracy, the first AD is the first, is the assistant director. It's sort of a misnomer. You know, they're not really assisting the director.
他们，他们管理着一切。如果他们不，如果他们不投入，如果他们不创造一个和谐的……这太真实了。这只是。肖恩，肖恩，你开始，你开始说特蕾西。所以，所以对于特蕾西，第一副导演就是助理导演。这有点用词不当。你知道，他们并不是真的在协助导演。
They're running the set. They run the entire set. They're the quarterback. And when you have a bad experience, that's when you really know how valuable they are, how valuable a good one is, because they can just take the whole thing down. And everybody takes advantage and it's just a mess. And it all falls apart. And it starts in a trap.
他们在管理片场。他们管理整个片场。他们是四分卫。当你经历糟糕时，你才会真正知道他们有多宝贵，一个好的有多宝贵，因为他们可以把整个事情搞砸。每个人都占便宜，这简直是一团糟。一切都分崩离析。而且它始于一个陷阱。
We need you on set. I need 10 minutes. And then they're like, ugh. And you can tell a set that you show up on that has a really great, strong first AD. You're like, oh, this, you know, this is going to be a good experience. Yeah. We'll be right back. Now a word from our sponsor, better help.
我们需要你在片场。我需要10分钟。然后他们就像，呃。你可以看出你到达的片场是否有一个非常棒、强大的第一副导演。你会想，哦，这个，你知道，这将是一次很好的体验。是的。我们马上回来。现在是我们的赞助商Better Help的一句话。
You know, recently I was in a situation where my character was in question and I didn't know how to handle it. It was kind of felt attacked and I was kind of, it was very, very personal to me. So I spoke to a therapist and she gave me the great advice of, you know, when you switch your brain instead of in panic mode and like freaking out, you calm your brain a little bit and have the tools to know how to calm your brain. You can come at a problem with a clearer head and more solutions. And that's exactly what happened in my situation.
你知道，最近我处于一种我的角色受到质疑的情况，我不知道该如何处理。我感觉受到了攻击，而且我当时，这对我来说非常，非常个人化。所以我咨询了一位治疗师，她给了我很好的建议，你知道，当你转换大脑而不是处于恐慌模式，像抓狂一样时，你让大脑平静一点，并拥有知道如何让大脑平静的工具。你可以用更清醒的头脑和更多的解决方案来处理问题。而这正是我当时的情况。
And it totally helped and everything got better and life went on. And it was just a little bump in the road. And that's how therapy can work. And it really does. It can be tough to train your brain to stay in problem solving mode when faced with a challenge in life. But when you learn how to find your own solutions, there's no better feeling. A therapist can help you become a better problem solver, making it easier to accomplish your
它完全有帮助，一切都变好了，生活继续。那只是路上的一个小坎坷。这就是治疗可以起作用的方式。它确实有效。当你面对生活中的挑战时，训练你的大脑保持在解决问题的模式可能很困难。但当你学会如何找到自己的解决方案时，没有比这更好的感觉了。治疗师可以帮助你成为一个更好的问题解决者，让你更容易实现你的
goals no matter how big or small. If you're thinking of giving therapy a try, better help is a great option. It's convenient, accessible, affordable and entirely online. Get matched with a therapist after filling out a brief survey and switch therapists anytime. When you want to be a better problem solver, therapy can get you there. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterHELP.com slash smartlist. It's the same with wireless.
目标，无论大小。如果你正在考虑尝试治疗，Better Help是一个很好的选择。它方便、易用、负担得起，而且完全在线。在完成简短的调查后与治疗师匹配，并随时更换治疗师。当你想要成为一个更好的问题解决者时，治疗可以带你到达那里。今天访问betterhelp.com/smartlist以获得首月10%的折扣。那是betterHELP.com/smartlist。无线网络也是一样。
Big carriers offer discounts on family plans, but that means you have to bring a lot of people with you. And if you only need one line, you definitely don't get that bulk discount. That's what makes visible wireless great and why we've talked about them recently. Get this. They offer a one line wireless plan with unlimited data and 5G for just $30 a month. Taxes and fees included. No catch, no annual contracts, no extra fees, and they're powered by Verizon.
大运营商提供家庭套餐折扣，但这意味着你必须带很多人一起。如果你只需要一条线路，你肯定得不到那种批量折扣。这就是Visible Wireless的伟大之处，也是我们最近谈论他们的原因。听着。他们提供一条无线线路套餐，包含无限数据和5G，每月仅需30美元。包含税费。没有陷阱，没有年度合同，没有额外费用，而且他们由Verizon提供支持。
Yep, you heard that right. So you can stream, browse, call and text all you want thanks to visible. Switch today at visible.com for data management practices. Learn more at visible.com. Additional terms apply. Thanks to one of our newest sponsors, the Gemological Institute of America for supporting the show. The Hope Diamond, the Idol's Eye, the Taylor Burton. These aren't just titles of my albums.
是的，你没听错。所以多亏了Visible，你可以随心所欲地流媒体、浏览、通话和发短信。今天就在visible.com切换。有关数据管理实践，请在visible.com了解更多。适用附加条款。感谢我们最新的赞助商之一，美国宝石研究院（GIA）对本节目的支持。希望之钻、偶像之眼、泰勒-伯顿。这些不仅仅是我专辑的标题。
Some of the most famous diamonds in the world have the same names, and they've been graded by the Gemological Institute of America, GIA. They're a longstanding scientific authority on diamonds and creators of the diamond 4Cs. Maybe you've heard of them, cut, clarity, color and carrot. I can imagine the process of like buying a diamond can feel like intimidating or like overwhelming because like most people don't sit down and study gems and cuts of diamonds and what to do for your girlfriend or your boyfriend or whatever if you want to get them like a ring with diamond or diamond studs or whatever.
世界上一些最著名的钻石也有同样的名字，它们都经过了美国宝石研究院（GIA）的评级。他们是钻石领域长期的科学权威，也是钻石4C标准的创造者。也许你听说过它们，切工、净度、颜色和克拉。我可以想象购买钻石的过程可能会让人感到令人生畏或不知所措，因为大多数人不会坐下来研究宝石和钻石切工，以及如果你想为你的女朋友或男朋友或任何你想送给他们的人买一枚带钻石的戒指或钻石耳钉之类的东西该怎么做。
Like it can be, I can't imagine it can be overwhelming. GIA grades the most precious diamonds in the world, including yours. Each diamond graded by GIA comes with a report with information about your diamond, including the 4Cs. Buy with confidence by choosing a diamond graded by the experts at GIA. Find out more at gia.edu. One more time, that's gia.edu. And now, back to the show. Lastly on the directing thing, Lizzy, what is your favorite thing that a director can do
就像它可能，我无法想象它可能会让人不知所措。GIA为世界上最珍贵的钻石进行评级，包括你的。每一颗经过GIA评级的钻石都附有一份报告，其中包含有关你钻石的信息，包括4C标准。通过选择经过GIA专家评级的钻石，自信地购买。在gia.edu了解更多信息。再说一次，是gia.edu。现在，回到节目。最后关于导演的事情，莉齐，你最喜欢导演能做的一件事是什么
and what's your least favorite thing and working with all the great directors that you've worked with and without naming any names, like the thing that you're avoiding when you're directing because you've seen someone else do it and then the other side, the thing that you like to do because you've seen it down really well. So just to repeat. Can you repeat that please? That's part of the madness, Sean. I'd like to give the answerer, that's a word right, time to...
你最不喜欢的一件事是什么，在你合作过的所有伟大的导演中，不点名，比如你作为导演时正在避免的事情，因为你见过别人这样做，然后另一面，你喜欢做的事情，因为你见过它做得很好。所以只是重复一下。你能重复一下吗？那是疯狂的一部分，肖恩。我想给回答者，那是个词对吧，时间来……
Your own answer is included in this question. He knows exactly what he's doing. I'd give them one they can use if they like. If he were in a court of law, the judge would be like, every time they'd be like, you're on or leading every single time. Just ask the question. I'm the worst. What do you like?
你自己的回答包含在这个问题里了。他完全知道自己在做什么。我会给他们一个他们喜欢的话，他们可以用。如果他在法庭上，法官会说，每次他们都会说，你是在诱导或引导，每一次。直接问问题。我是最差的。你喜欢什么？
Just go like, what do you like? What's your favorite? Then that's it. Or is it and is it? She'll tell you. All right. Liz, I'm sorry. Do we have time for me to answer?
就说，你喜欢什么？你最喜欢什么？然后就这样。或者它是，它是吗？她会告诉你的。好吧。莉兹，对不起。我们有时间让我回答吗？
Okay. Well, I'll start with my favorite thing, which comes to mind easier. This I learned from Jane, I think, just the atmosphere created on set, that she had... For which show? Sorry, for which show? For Top of the Lake. Yeah.
好吧。嗯，我会从我最喜欢的事情开始，这更容易想到。这是我从简那里学到的，我想，只是在片场创造的氛围，她有……为了哪部剧？抱歉，为了哪部剧？为了《顶湖》。是的。
So she just had this ability to create an atmosphere on set that you never felt rushed, you never felt under pressure. I mean, with, you know, given, there were some times, but just in general, you always felt like you had time to rehearse if you wanted to or ask questions. There was just no ticking clock. And to do that, now that I am on the other side, I know how difficult that actually is to do.
所以她只是有这种能力在片场创造一种氛围，让你从不感到匆忙，从不感到压力。我是说，你知道，虽然，确实有几次，但总的来说，你总是觉得如果你想排练或问问题，你有时间。根本没有滴答作响的时钟。要做到这一点，现在我站在另一边，我知道这实际上有多难。
Because you're almost suppressing your own anxiety. Oh my God, of course. And you know, like that... Tick, tick, tick, tick, tick. Yeah. And this actor has a question. You're like, Jesus Christ, we're not going to get the scene. So I know how difficult it actually is now,
因为你几乎是在压抑自己的焦虑。哦天哪，当然。而且你知道，就像那个……滴答，滴答，滴答，滴答。是的。而这个演员有一个问题。你会想，天哪，我们拍不完这场戏了。所以我现在知道这实际上有多难，
but she just did it so flawlessly. And I'm not as good at it as she is by any means, but it is something I kind of try to keep reminding myself to do. And you have to... So I think the answer to the other question is just the reverse of that, Jason. Yes, is somebody who is clearly anxious, clearly... I mean, the worst thing that can possibly happen is, you know, after you do a take, a director just sort of sits there
但她做得如此完美。我无论如何都没有她那么好，但这确实是我试图不断提醒自己去做的事情。而且你必须……所以我认为另一个问题的答案正好相反，杰森。是的，就是那种明显焦虑的人，明显……我是说，可能发生的最糟糕的事情是，你知道，在你拍完一条后，导演只是坐在那里
and doesn't sort of know what to say, you know, and there's that awful kind of thing where they're like, I just... Well, okay, let's just go again. Let's just try it. And that's the worst, you know. Because it's different than what they thought it was going to be, and they can't figure out whether that means it's wrong or not.
不知道该说什么，你知道，而且有一种可怕的事情，他们会说，我只是……好吧，好吧，我们再来一次。让我们试一试。那是，你知道，最糟糕的。因为这和他们想的不一样，他们无法弄清楚这是否意味着它是错的。
Right, right. And they just don't know how to fix it if they do need to fix it. And they should just... They just move on and maybe they're thinking about how they can cut around it. You know what I want? I want to veer off this for just a second. Okay.
对，对。如果他们确实需要修复它，他们只是不知道如何修复。他们应该只是……他们只是继续前进，也许他们在想如何绕过它剪辑。你知道我想要什么吗？我想暂时偏离这个话题。好吧。
I want to talk to you, Elizabeth. I'm sorry, Lizzie, about vacation. What do you do on your time off? Because your resume... You just grabbed the wheel and just drove us off a fucking cliff. What's going on? Put us in the back seat and... I've never been in a conversation before.
我想和你谈谈，伊丽莎白。抱歉，莉齐，关于假期。你休息时做什么？因为你的简历……你只是抓住了方向盘，把我们开下了该死的悬崖。怎么回事？把我们放在后座，然后……我以前从未参加过这样的对话。
We're talking shop, Sean. What are you? Fucking Jesus. It's the business tree. That's the new name of the podcast. Cupcakes and vacays. Yeah, you know what I mean? Yeah, so would you rather sun or snow?
我们在谈论工作，肖恩。你是，该死的耶稣。这是商业树。那是播客的新名字。纸杯蛋糕和假期。是的，你知道我的意思吗？是的，所以你更喜欢阳光还是雪？
Sun or snow for the vacation? Sun. Sun for sure. With that skin of yours, it's perfect. Yeah, big hats. Sun, although I haven't gone on a proper vacation a little bit. And recently, the last vacation I took was to Paris over Christmas and New Year's last year,
度假是阳光还是雪？阳光。肯定是阳光。以你那样的皮肤，太完美了。是的，大帽子。阳光，虽然我有一段时间没去正经度假了。最近，我上次度假是去年圣诞节和新年去巴黎，
which is neither sun nor snow. But absolutely wonderful, of course. Do you speak French? No, I do not. I have to learn for my next role. Really? Yeah, I have to do a British accent and also learn French.
那既不是阳光也不是雪。但当然绝对美妙。你会说法语吗？不，我不会。我必须为我的下一个角色学习。真的吗？是的，我必须用英国口音，还要学习法语。
That's lunch, guys. So you're playing a Frenchy in your next thing. I'm playing a British person who speaks French. Oh, wow. There's Mark Chappell. Mark Chappell is a British person who speaks French. He can help you. It's once an episode.
那是午餐时间，伙计们。所以你在下一部戏里演一个法国人。我演一个会说法语的英国人。哦，哇。那是马克·查佩尔。马克·查佩尔是一个会说法语的英国人。他可以帮你。一集一次。
Sure. If he gets mentioned. Sure, if he gets mentioned. Is it a bet you guys are in? He's a great guy. But Lizzie, I went on vacation with Jason this summer. We went to the Bahamas. He sure did.
当然。如果他被提到的话。当然，如果他被提到的话。你们是在打赌吗？他是个很棒的人。但莉齐，我今年夏天和杰森去度假了。我们去了巴哈马。他确实去了。
And we went, every time we would go into the ocean, my pasty white skin would be, I would just wear my bathing shorts. And my pasties would come off. And Jason looked like he was gardening in the ocean. Like he had this massive straw hat on that covered his whole body. You know why? Because I have a smart other half.
而且我们去了，每次我们进入海洋，我那苍白的皮肤就会，我只会穿我的泳裤。我的苍白就会露出来。而杰森看起来就像在海里园艺。就像他戴着一顶巨大的草帽，遮住了他的整个身体。你知道为什么吗？因为我有一个聪明的另一半。
Yeah, but long sleeve shirt, super long shorts, like the sun just finds him. Listen, when he gets hit by a bus next week, it's going to make a big difference. Hey. He's not smart though. It's important to protect him. Yeah, he's smart.
是的，但长袖衬衫，超长短裤，就像太阳就是会找到他。听着，当他下周被公共汽车撞到时，那会有很大的不同。嘿。但他不聪明。保护他是很重要的。是的，他很聪明。
Sure. We'll bury him with that fucking hat. Listen, we went on vacation with the kids and stuff a few years ago. And everybody's like, we're all in the water. There are like 15 of us except for at the end. There's Jason fully covered from ankle to wrist with the hat. Do you burn Jason? I have burned before, but also panel.
当然。我们会戴着那顶该死的帽子埋葬他。听着，几年前我们和孩子们一起去度假之类的。每个人都像，我们都在水里。我们大概有15个人，除了最后。杰森从脚踝到手腕完全覆盖，戴着帽子。你会被晒伤吗，杰森？我以前晒伤过，但也，面板。
I have had sun cancer removed from my face. Oh, I didn't know that. Okay. I didn't know that. That's awkward. Yeah. When was that? Oh, and I don't bother people with my near death experiences.
我的脸上切除过皮肤癌。哦，我不知道。好吧。我不知道。那很尴尬。是的。那是什么时候？哦，我不会用我的濒死体验去打扰别人。
We've really stepped in it. Sean. Well, wait a minute. When was that? How long ago was the son of a bitch? How long ago was that? Nothing. So Lizzie and I, because I don't want to run, so Lizzie and I last year, I came in,
我们真的踩到雷了。肖恩。好吧，等一下。那是什么时候？那个混蛋是什么时候？那是什么时候？没什么。所以莉齐和我，因为我不想跑，所以莉齐和我去年，我进来了，
and Lizzie's in this in Tychus movie, Next Goal Wins. And then I came in and we, I just shot for a couple days. Oh, this is the thing you just shot? Yeah. For a couple of days. Is this where you guys kissed? And where we kissed. Oh.
莉齐在那个《下一球成名》电影里。然后我进来了，我们，我只是拍了几天。哦，这是你刚拍的东西？是的。拍了几天。这是你们接吻的地方吗？也是我们接吻的地方。哦。
And we celebrate this moment and Lizzie turns me and goes, should we kiss? And I go, yeah, I guess so. And they're like, and action. It was just like that. Wow. It was just like that. There were no questions. So listener, Tracy, there's a situation when an actor's kiss, it's never in the script,
我们庆祝这一刻，莉齐转向我说，我们要接吻吗？我说，是的，我想是吧。然后他们说，开始。就是那样。哇。就是那样。没有问题。所以听众，特蕾西，有一种情况是当演员接吻时，剧本里从来没有，
whether the mouth opens or stays closed. Yeah, let's talk about that. You need to kind of understand what kind of kiss it is, right? Is it passionate or is it celebratory? And it's a little see you tomorrow and a little peck. Have you discussed it? There's a, I don't often discuss it. You just kind of supposed to know.
嘴是张开还是闭着。是的，让我们谈谈那个。你需要了解那是什么样的吻，对吧？是热情的还是庆祝的？这是一个小小的明天见和一个小小的啄吻。你们讨论过吗？有一种，我不经常讨论它。你只是应该知道。
I feel like you have to discuss it. You're supposed to now. Did you guys discuss? We did not. You did not discuss. Did the mouth open? No, it was kind of just like, it was like, it was a quick, it was like a celebratory, like a really celebratory moment.
我觉得你必须讨论它。你现在应该了。你们讨论过吗？我们没有。你们没有讨论。嘴张开了吗？不，它只是像，它就像，这是一个快速的，它就像一个庆祝的，就像一个非常庆祝的时刻。
So it was like, One of you seems sure about that. Did tongues touch at all? I don't think so. Still not real sure are you? No, no, no, no, because it was like we were happy. We're like, all right, they scored. And then we sort of hugged and then kissed.
所以它就像，你们中有一个人看起来很确定。舌头接触了吗？我不这么认为。还是不太确定，是吗？不，不，不，不，因为就像我们很高兴。我们就像，好吧，他们得分了。然后我们拥抱了一下，然后接吻了。
And I did ask. I just want it noted that will said I did ask. There was consent. She did ask. So it was a celebration over a kid's soccer goal. Not a kid. Not a child. A real.
而且我确实问了。我只是想记录下来，威尔说我确实问了。有同意。她确实问了。所以这是一个关于孩子足球进球的庆祝。不是孩子。不是小孩。一个真正的。
Oh, well, you're not going to tongue kiss on a celebration. It was a quick moment. But normally when you would do any sort of love scene or kiss, yeah, there would be sort of, especially now there's even more conversation. They have a person on set. They actually have a intimacy. Intimacy. Intimacy.
哦，好吧，你不会在庆祝时舌吻。那是一个快速的时刻。但通常当你做任何类型的爱情戏或接吻时，是的，会有某种，特别是现在有更多的对话。他们在片场有一个人。他们实际上有一个亲密。亲密。亲密。
But we have either, have any of you here on the, as Jason calls the panel, the panel, have you ever had a moment where you had to kiss somebody in a scene on any job and you open the mouth, but no tongue? Because I think that's incredibly awkward. A lot. Yeah. That's so weird. It is weird.
但我们有，你们这里有任何人，正如杰森所说的面板，面板，你有没有过在任何工作中必须在场景中亲吻某人，你张开了嘴，但没有舌头？因为我觉得那非常尴尬。很多。是的。那太奇怪了。确实很奇怪。
It is weird. That's like, that's like fake cutting me a piece of cake. It's like, wait, wait. So the goal there, the goal there would be so that camera can see that, oh, this is a passionate kiss, right? Because you see the jaws moving and stuff like that. But you're already halfway there. Why not just insert the tongue?
确实很奇怪。那就像，那就像假装切一块蛋糕给我。就像，等等，等等。所以那里的目标，那里的目标是为了让摄像机看到，哦，这是一个热情的吻，对吧？因为你看到下巴在动之类的。但你已经做了一半了。为什么不直接插入舌头？
Well, I think the tongue is considered just the level of intimacy that some people aren't ready or wanting to go to. I'm with you. I think if there's, you know, there's a discussion and consent and everything and everyone's on the same page. I'm with you, Sean, where it's sort of like, well, at this point, I mean, God, you know, you might as well make it look real. I had to make out with Katie Finneron on stage and promises, promises every night.
嗯，我认为舌头被认为是某些人还没准备好或不想达到的亲密程度。我和你一样。我认为如果有，你知道，有讨论和同意，每个人都在同一页上。我和你一样，肖恩，就像是，好吧，在这一点上，我是说，天哪，你知道，你还不如让它看起来真实。我必须每晚在舞台上和凯蒂·芬内伦在《承诺，承诺》中亲热。
And we just fucking sloppy wet tongue kissed every night. It's all about comfort too. You know, I find that if you've just met the person or if there's something that you don't, you know, you're a little, you're much more sort of cautious of what they're comfortable with. But most of the time there's somebody that like on, if you're on a series, it's not your first kiss. But Sean is a loose cannon.
我们每晚都该死地湿吻。这也关乎舒适度。你知道，我发现如果你刚认识那个人，或者有什么你不，你知道，你有点，你对他们舒服的事情更加谨慎。但大多数时候，有人像在，如果你在一部剧里，那不是你的初吻。但肖恩是个脱缰的野马。
He got a massage. He popped a bone getting a massage recently from a woman. He's all over the map. He doesn't know what's going on. It's a true story. You said it. It's a true story. Wait, this was in the Bahamas, right?
他按摩了。他最近从一个女人那里按摩时弄断了一根骨头。他到处都是。他不知道发生了什么。这是一个真实的故事。你说出来了。这是一个真实的故事。等等，这是在巴哈马，对吧？
After we got out of the ocean. That's right. He had a, he had a treatment. Yeah. And Jason had one still in his gardening outfit. How did you deal with that? Well, she did a lot of drive-bys, right? A lot of brush-bys.
我们从海里出来之后。没错。他有一个，他有一个治疗。是的。杰森还有一个仍然穿着他的园艺装。你是怎么处理的？嗯，她做了很多次擦身而过，对吧？很多次擦身。
It wasn't his fault. She was being inappropriate. A lot. And then, and yeah, and it was a small towel over it. And then it just kind of lifted and she just didn't care. Where was this? This is the Bahamas. This is the Bahamas on this incredible trip that they went on,
那不是他的错。她表现得不合适。很多。然后，是的，上面有一条小毛巾。然后它就那样掀起来了，她根本不在乎。这是在哪里？这是巴哈马。这是巴哈马，在他们去的那次不可思议的旅行中，
that I did not go on for. Weren't invited to? Well, you don't like sandals. They claim they invited me, but I don't remember. Actually, the last time I did that, I said I wasn't invited to something. I think there's an email for this too. Printed an email to prove that I'd never answered.
我没有去。没被邀请？嗯，你不喜欢凉鞋。他们声称邀请了我，但我记不起来了。实际上，我上次那样做时，我说我没被邀请参加什么东西。我想这也有电子邮件。打印了一封电子邮件来证明我从未回复。
But here's the thing. I'm worried about, like anytime I've done a kiss on screen, I'm always worried that they're going to fall in love with me. Yeah. Yeah. Because my kissing, yeah. A mile away. You know what I mean?
但问题是。我担心，就像我每次在屏幕上接吻时，我总是担心他们会爱上我。是的。是的。因为我的接吻，是的。一英里远。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah. Because they're only human. They can't help themselves. One of those kisses on them. Lizzie, I bet it was you had probably a couple of days afterwards. Like what are, what are you going to do? I wouldn't leave town. I was showing up outside his house.
是的。因为他们只是凡人。他们无法自拔。其中一个吻在他们身上。莉齐，我敢打赌那是你，可能之后有几天。就像你打算怎么办？我不会离开镇子。我会在他家外面出现。
Right. Lizzie, aside from that stuff, like I dating, you want to date kids, marriage, anything like that. Say again. What's the question? Kids, dating, marriage, anything in your life right now. You just reaching into a grab bag and just slide that in there. Why not?
对。Lizzie，除了那些，比如约会，你想约会、生孩子、结婚之类的吗？再说一遍。什么问题？孩子、约会、结婚，你现在生活中的任何事。你就像从抓取袋里随便抓一个出来，然后顺口提一下。为什么不呢？
Personal stuff. Go ahead. You don't have to answer it. I like Sean. Sean and I are good. I feel safe with him. First personal questions. All right.
私事。说吧。你不用回答。我喜欢Sean。我和Sean关系很好。和他在一起我很有安全感。先问私事。好吧。
I'm visiting with, I'm visiting you when I'm in New York. I would love that, honestly. It's kind of weird that we've never met. No, it is. Right? Anyway, I'm single. What's your sign? Nothing going on.
我到纽约的时候会去拜访你。说实话，我很乐意。我们从来没见过面，这有点奇怪。不，确实是。对吧？总之，我是单身。你是什么星座？没什么进展。
Leo. What's your rising? I don't know. Special skills. We've never had that done. Horseback riding. Okay. Good.
狮子座。你的上升星座是什么？我不知道。特殊技能。我们从来没做过那个。骑马。好的。不错。
Great. You work for Tinder? Just updating her profile. Taekwondo. Just updating my Wikipedia. So no single. I would love to have kids at some point soon. That's good.
太棒了。你在Tinder工作吗？只是在更新她的个人资料。跆拳道。只是在更新我的维基百科。所以不是单身。我希望在不久的将来能生孩子。那很好。
You're a damn match. You are a real catch. I'll keep an eye out. Yeah. We both will. For children? For many many people off this podcast. No.
你真是个绝配。你真是个抢手货。我会留意的。是的。我们都会。为孩子？为这个播客之外的许多许多人。不。
No, for children. Any loose girls running around? And available children that aren't any. All right. Maybe this is out of bounds for me to say, but Sean, why don't you donate some sperm for, so Lizzie can have a try? Look at it. Don't threaten me because I'll do it.
不，是为了孩子。有什么单身女孩在附近吗？还有什么可用的孩子，虽然并没有。好吧。也许我说这话有点越界了，但Sean，你为什么不捐点精子，让Lizzie试试呢？看看它。别威胁我，因为我会做的。
Really? No, why not? I am on board. Now there are, there are banks, right? I've heard about these. You can look through like these profiles, these pages and pages of, of different donors. Oh yeah. Or I could just go at it, and I'll close my eyes
真的吗？不，为什么不呢？我同意。现在有精子库，对吧？我听说过这些。你可以浏览这些个人资料，一页又一页的捐赠者。哦，是的。或者我可以就这样做，然后闭上眼睛
and hold my breath. Or I could just give you a massage, and apparently. Yeah, that's all it takes. I've been creating a bank here. I've got a jug that I've been for the last couple of years. Hey, man. I keep it in the back fridge. I keep it in the back fridge, and I just.
屏住呼吸。或者我可以给你做个按摩，显然。是的，这就足够了。我一直在建立一个库。过去几年我一直有个罐子。嘿，伙计。我把它放在后面的冰箱里。我把它放在后面的冰箱里，然后我就。
Keep it in the back fridge. Fridge in the garage. A jug. It's just open, just like a lid. It's just like an old-timey plank. It's like rusty. So speaking of perfect days, Liz, so if you aren't working on one of these great things,
放在后面的冰箱里。车库里的冰箱。一个罐子。它只是开着的，就像个盖子。就像个老式的木板。它看起来生锈了。说到完美的一天，Liz，如果你不在做这些伟大的事情之一，
which I would assume would be a perfect day for you, what would be the second most perfect day? What do you really like to do with your days if you're not working, not watching real housewives? In New York. Well, you're right about the first thing. My ideal day is such a nerd is working, being on set. Otherwise, I do love being in New York,
我想那对你来说应该是完美的一天，那么第二完美的一天是什么？如果你不工作，不看《比弗利娇妻》，你真正喜欢做什么？在纽约。嗯，你说对了一件事。我理想的一天，我是个书呆子，就是工作，在片场。除此之外，我确实喜欢待在纽约，
and I don't get to be here as often as I would like, so definitely in New York, it has just become fall here. New York got the memo. Yesterday was the first day of fall. New York is ready. New York was literally like five, six, seven, eight, and showtime. Here we are.
我没法像我希望的那样经常来这里，所以绝对是在纽约，这里刚刚入秋。纽约收到了通知。昨天是秋天的第一天。纽约准备好了。纽约简直就像是五、六、七、八，演出开始。我们到了。
Like, it is crisp. It is amazing how. You like rent one of those bikes and just start touring around, or you just start walking around like Mary Tyler Moore? Mary Tyler Moore. I love walking. It's why I couldn't live in LA.
就像，空气很清爽。这太神奇了。你租一辆那种自行车然后开始四处游览，或者你就像玛丽·泰勒·摩尔一样四处走动？玛丽·泰勒·摩尔。我喜欢走路。这就是我为什么不能住在洛杉矶的原因。
I love walking around the city, right? So no plans. I don't like plans, because unstructured time is something that I don't get a lot of. So I'll see you when I see it. Exactly. Just run into you in the park. Now, are you a night owl?
我喜欢在城市里走来走去，对吧？所以没有计划。我不喜欢计划，因为非结构化的时间是我很少得到的。所以我到时候再看吧。没错。就在公园里偶遇你。那么，你是夜猫子吗？
Are you one of those people that really takes advantage of like the whole restaurant scene in New York and you're out till, you know, you eat at like 1030 and that stuff? No, no, no, no. I love an early dinner. You know, I'm perfectly happy with a dinner at six. I think that's absolutely acceptable.
你是那种真正利用纽约整个餐厅场景的人吗？你出去到，你知道，你在10点半吃饭之类的？不，不，不，不。我喜欢早点吃晚饭。你知道，我六点吃晚饭就很满足了。我认为这绝对是可以接受的。
I'd push it to 530. Absolutely, why not? Five o'clock, let's go. I had dinner at five almost a night. I love it. When I was younger, I was a little bit, I was definitely more of a night owl for sure. And yeah, it started to, definitely started to change.
我会把它提前到5点半。绝对，为什么不呢？五点钟，走吧。我几乎每天晚上五点吃晚饭。我喜欢这样。我年轻的时候，确实更像个夜猫子。是的，它开始，绝对开始改变了。
Uptown or downtown? Uptown, Upper West. Upper West, near Sean. No way. Yeah. Wow. Are you there now? No, I'm there for all of 2023.
上城还是下城？上城，上西区。上西区，靠近Sean。不会吧。是的。哇。你现在在那儿吗？不，我2023年全年都在那儿。
Here comes Tonglass Kissing. I'm telling you, I tell you what. Sean, you want to borrow my jug? You can pick it up. Just drop it off. I have a doorman building. I'll post it on it and you're all set. We don't, we don't even have to talk.
Tonglass Kissing来了。我告诉你，我跟你说。Sean，你想借我的罐子吗？你可以去拿。把它放下就行。我有门卫大楼。我会贴个条，你就搞定了。我们甚至不需要说话。
Hey, Sean Hayes is going to come by and drop something off. Wow. It's not labeled, just accept it. Just throw it in the freezer. Do not drink it or. Well, we're going to end on a high note here. And we're going to thank you for your time. Oh, Lizzie, we love you.
嘿，Sean Hayes要过来放下点东西。哇。没贴标签，直接收下就行。把它扔进冰箱。别喝它或者。好吧，我们要以高调结束。我们要感谢你抽出时间。哦，Lizzie，我们爱你。
Your humor, your generosity, your spirit. I love you. Yeah. I love you guys. Lizzie, you know what the thing you did was, you actually, Jason was really grumpy this morning and you did turn his day around. Yeah, you turned that front upside down.
你的幽默，你的慷慨，你的精神。我爱你。是的。我也爱你们。Lizzie，你知道你做的那件事，你实际上，Jason今天早上真的很暴躁，你确实扭转了他的一天。是的，你让他转忧为喜了。
You really did, legit. Couple of thumbs up. I knew you would. Thank you. I know, I heard you. I'm so happy I could and thanks for having me. I requested to be on this podcast because I'm such a big fan of it.
你真的做到了，合法的。几个大拇指。我就知道你会的。谢谢。我知道，我听到了。我很高兴我能做到，谢谢你们邀请我。我申请参加这个播客，因为我是它的忠实粉丝。
Oh, that's so. You didn't need to ask twice. How is that possible? Thank you. You're so great and you're such an unbelievable mega talent. It's just so great having you. Keep going. Keep giving us your stuff. Super nice person.
哦，那太好了。你不需要问两次。这怎么可能？谢谢。你太棒了，你是一个令人难以置信的超级天才。有你在真是太好了。继续努力。继续给我们带来你的东西。超级好的人。
Thanks. I appreciate it. Thank you. I think it should be under her eye. Under her eye. Oh, I like it. She's running out there. Okay.
谢谢。我很感激。谢谢。我认为它应该在她的眼睛下面。在她的眼睛下面。哦，我喜欢它。她跑出去了。好的。
Look at you. Lizzie, you're the best. Have a great rest of the day. We'll speak to you. Thank you. I hope. Awesome. Thanks guys.
看看你。Lizzie，你是最棒的。祝你余下的一天过得愉快。我们再联系。谢谢。我希望。太棒了。谢谢你们。
Cartman 5a, Sean. Thank you. Okay, thank you. Get there. Take the door open. Bye. Bye. Thank you. Bye.
Cartman 5a，Sean。谢谢。好的，谢谢。到了。把门打开。再见。再见。谢谢。再见。
That was so funny. I mean, I never met her. How do you know her, Jason? We talked about doing some work together, like that kind of thing. Nothing structured. The nose or your brow or what? Well, we were going to get a two for just a brow lift.
那太搞笑了。我是说，我从来没见过她。你怎么认识她的，Jason？我们谈过一起做些工作，类似那种事情。没有结构化的。鼻子还是眉毛还是什么？嗯，我们本来要去做个双人眉毛提升。
And that's so funny. She's amazing. I tell you a funny story. I don't know why they didn't tell her the thing. We were laughing too much. So when my ex-wife Amy was pregnant with Archie and it was right up almost the day she was, it was her original due date.
那太搞笑了。她太棒了。我给你讲个有趣的故事。我不知道他们为什么没告诉她那件事。我们笑得太厉害了。所以当我的前妻Amy怀着Archie的时候，几乎就在她预产期的那天。
And she had a doctor's appointment and the doctor was like, no, it's going to be another week or whatever. And then that night after Friday night, she did a joke run through for update with Tina and it came home and then like her water broke and it was a Friday night, we went up to the hospital and then the next day,
她有个医生预约，医生说，不，还要再过一周之类的。然后那天晚上周五晚上之后，她和Tina做了一次更新节目的排练，然后回家了，然后她的羊水破了，那是周五晚上，我们去了医院，然后第二天，
Archie was born. It was the first time that Ham that weekend that Hammer was, John was hosting SNL. And they were going to do this sketch that Amy was going to do with them bubble blood. And she kind of, they had to replace her in all these sketches. And Lizzie happened to be in town
Archie出生了。那是Hammer那个周末第一次，John主持SNL。他们本来要演这个小品，Amy要和他们一起演泡泡血。他们不得不替换掉她所有的这些小品。而Lizzie正好在城里，
because John was hosting SNL. And so she came and filled in for Amy. That's amazing. Wait, on update too? Not an update. No, no, no, just on the show. And the sketches and stuff. That's super fun.
因为John在主持SNL。所以她来了，代替了Amy。太神奇了。等等，更新节目也代替了吗？不是更新节目。不，不，不，只是在节目里。还有小品之类的。那太有趣了。
Isn't that cool? That's so cool. Yeah. I can't believe I've never met her. Yeah, she's amazing. She's great. Yeah, she really is. What a talent.
那不是很酷吗？那太酷了。是的。我不敢相信我从来没见过她。是的，她太棒了。她很棒。是的，她确实是。真是个天才。
She's an unreal talent. Isn't she funny and funny too? I want to hear in like some comedies. She's so mellow. Yeah, she is. She's in the best way as a compliment. We got to set her up. Let's make that a smart guess.
她是个不可思议的天才。她不是很幽默吗？我想在一些喜剧里听到她。她很随和。是的，她是。这是最好的赞美。我们得给她安排一下。让我们把它变成一个聪明的猜测。
That's my ask. I'm gonna find her. Yeah, let's set her up. Let's set her up. I'm gonna put a list together right now. Yeah. Her past smart list guests. Yeah, past smart list.
这是我的要求。我要找到她。是的，让我们给她安排一下。让我们给她安排一下。我现在要列个名单。是的。她过去的SmartLess嘉宾。是的，过去的SmartLess。
And just guys who are going to be released the next year or so. Guys that are. Who are on parole, but like more like white collar. Sure. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. No, she deserves a great dude. What do you guys got the rest of the day?
还有那些明年左右要发布的家伙。那些。正在假释的人，但更像是白领。当然。是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的。不，她值得一个很棒的男人。你们今天剩下的时间打算做什么？
I'm going to go to an eye doctor cause I have an eye infection. Are you going to take some notes for the next episode of hypochondriactor? Yeah, actually I am. Hey, have you prepared stories that you want to open the show with for a next show? Sure.
我要去看眼科医生，因为我眼睛感染了。你要为下一集《疑病症患者》做笔记吗？是的，其实我是。嘿，你准备好要在下一集节目开头讲的故事了吗？当然。
I can do that. Sean, why not? No, because. I don't prepare them. I'm just like, oh, this happened today. Yeah. So I'll talk about that. You'll log it.
我可以做到。Sean，为什么不呢？不，因为。我没准备它们。我只是觉得，哦，今天发生了这个。是的。所以我到时候会讲。你会记录下来的。
You've got, you're going to help the planet by doing what? By. Nine holes of golf. Well, I'm going to work. I got a little bit of work to do. I'm going to watch some, I'm going to watch some, some soccer, some UEFA nations. Watch some soccer, watch some golf,
你打算通过做什么来帮助地球？通过。打九洞高尔夫。嗯，我要工作。我还有点工作要做。我要看一些，我要看一些，一些足球，一些欧国联。看一些足球，看一些高尔夫，
then go play some golf and then leave your car running just so the air conditioning can be on in a parking lot somewhere. You know what? Sometimes, sometimes, you know, in order you got to let things go. Or as I always say, let by guns be. Bye.
然后去打打高尔夫，然后让你的车开着，只是为了让停车场里的空调能开着。你知道吗？有时候，有时候，你知道，为了你得放手。或者正如我常说的，让过去成为过去。再见。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Sean, you don't need to do at the bye, OK? Fuck. Why not?
再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。Sean，你不需要做那个再见，好吗？该死。为什么不呢？
You don't fucking say it. I got to make up for you. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbicó.
你他妈的别说。我得为你弥补。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess是由Michael Grant Terry、Rob Armjalf和Bennett Barbicó 100%有机且手工制作的。
Smart. Less. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry App.
SmartLess。我们的下一集将在下周发布，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在Amazon Music上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts或Wondry App上的Wondry Plus提前且无广告收听。
Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。